diane va amener d'autres façons de faire
des affaires et les choses dont beaucoup
se concentrer sur l'humain et sur
l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette
réinitialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différente qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de la formation
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 23
juin à cette reprise cédric joue via
indiqué aux policiers qui l'étouffé
résultats d'une expertise rendue
publique aujourd'hui
ce livre est mort à la suite d'un
contrôle policier début janvier à paris
des policiers désormais sous la menace
d'une mise en examen la famille de la
victime réclame leur suspension et des
actions du gouvernement contre les
violences policières
nouvelle polémique a pour le parti
présidentiel à quelques jours du second
tour des élections municipales selon une
enquête de mediapart laetitia avia
candidate alarm à la mairie du 12e
arrondissement de paris est soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé des ressources
parlementaire pour mener sa campagne
une révélation qui intervient un peu
après un camouflet pour les députés dont
la loi contre la haine en ligne était
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
[Musique]
la restauration et d'hôtellerie mise à
mal en raison de la crise sanitaire en
france les salariés intermittents de ce
secteur ont mené une action coup de
poing ce matin à paris en se muant une
marche funèbre
ils réclament un plan d'urgence pour
leur profession et s'oppose à la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
une délégation devrait être reçue
prochainement par pure muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail
[Musique]
l'allemagne qui décrète un deuxième
reconfirme en local le premier concerne
notamment un canton de 360 milles
habitants dans l'ouest du pays mis à l'
isolement jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
une mesure décrétée après l'apparition
d'un foyer de contamination dans un
grand abattoir où plus de 1500 cas
d'infection ont été détectés cette
mesure vise à calmer la situation et
accroître les tests
[Musique]
du nouveau dans la sphère cédric
souvient on a appris la garde à vue de
quatre fonctionnaires de police pendant
son interpellation
ce père de famille a crié j'étouffe à
sept reprises
les faits remontent au 3 janvier 2020 au
bord de seine à paris ce livreur de 42
ans est victime d'une fracture du larynx
après une interpellation il décède deux
jours plus tard à l'hôpital
des vidéos tournées par la victime ont
conduit la justice à placer les quatre
policiers mis en cause en garde à vue
une information judiciaire est ouverte
pour homicide involontaire ses avocats
dénoncent les méthodes d'arrestation de
la police les précisions avec notre
reporter 4 ça pique nique la sphère ctq
souvient rebondi
selon des enregistrements récemment
versé au dossier d' enquêtes judiciaires
le père de famille a crié cette fois
j'étouffe avant de perdre connaissance
le 3 janvier 2020 il décédera deux jours
plus tard des suites d'une fracture du
larynx occasionnés par son
immobilisation par une clé
d'étranglement et par un placage
ventrale depuis le début la famille de
cédric souvient crient à la bavure
policière
il se trouve que ces enregistrements que
se sont procurés le monde et mediapart
vont peser dans l' enquête judiciaire
ils contredisent les propos des quatre
policiers qui avaient procédé à sept
interpellations
les avocats de la famille souvient
aujourd'hui ont tenu une conférence de
presse je vous propose de les écouter ce
qui a conduit à la mort de cédric joue
via c'est un enchaînement inexorable
c'est-à-dire ce chantage à l'outragé qui
est provoquée à chaque fois que des
personnes sont contrôlées les
fonctionnaires de police quand il
contrôle des gens savent qu'ils ont une
dissymétrie et qu'ils peuvent les
poursuivre pour outrage et donc il ya
une provocation à l'outragé face à un
homme et de rien a rappelé tragiquement
qui dit je ne peux plus respirer cette
fois dondon dans les jambes et frappe le
macadam pour dire qu'il est pas loin
l'agonie les policiers de façon tout à
fait insensé fonds linverse
on va faire c'est à dire s'arrêter des
experts de l'institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie nationale
ont donc analysé 13 vidéos dont celle de
cédric joue via et de la policière
présente sur les lieux
il dispose également d'un enregistrement
sonore de 12 minutes
il a été effectué grâce à un micro qui
se trouvait dans le casque de cédric
joue via les experts ont rendu un
rapport le 21 avril
il déclare je cite l'échangé
relativement correcte même si nous
pouvons ressentir une forme de défiance
et de provocation dans les paroles de la
personne contrôlée selon l' enquête de
l'igpn est les quatre policiers auraient
déclaré que cédric souvient s'est montré
irrespectueux agressif et menaçant
et ce sont ces outrages qui aurait mené
à l'interpellation
or à l'écouté des enregistrements on se
rend compte que cédric souvient a bien
adopté un ton provocateur mais les
insultes en question son guignol clowns
ou encore pauvre type
nulle trace d'agressivité ni de menaces
dans ses propos en revanche à des
policiers a eu un commentaires
dégradants
il a dit aux livreurs tu veux pas que je
mettre à quatre pattes et que je te
coupe où je vous laisse imaginer la
vulgarité des propos tenus les quatre
policiers impliqués dans
l'interpellation de cédric joue via ont
été entendus le 17 juin à la demande du
juge d'instruction entendu en garde à
vue c'est une procédure rare mais ils
n'ont pas été suspendu et leur mise en
examen ne reste qu'une éventualité
les avocats de la famille ont en tout
cas à déposer une plainte avec
constitution de partie civile pour
violence volontaire d'une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
les avocats de la famille demande en
outre à christophe castaner d'interdire
le placage ventrale est la clé
d'étranglement des techniques décriés
pour leur dangerosité potentielle et
pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian show via le père de cédric
joue via bonsoir question info via berne
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
connaît désormais entre guillemets
officiellement les derniers mots de
votre fils j'étouffe dix à sept reprises
qui font évidemment en dramatiquement
écho à se prononcer par giorgio floyd
aux états unis quel est votre état
d'esprit votre réaction ce soir bonsoir
bah notre état d'esprit à la famille et
moi on est c'était dur on va prendre ça
on l'a supporté parce que on pensait
bien que cédric était pas mort en muet
par contre qu'il avait affaire à des
sourds puisque ils ont pas entendu
qu'ils disaient cette fois je respire
plus je respire plus je respire plus je
respire plus je respire plus je respire
plus je respire plus je suis je perds
même être trompés ils n'ont pas entendu
parce que maintenant on a appris que
dans la police on embauche à aussi les
sourds dont il ya plus d'un handicap
aujourd'hui bientôt en grand il faudrait
peut-être commencer à embaucher des
manchots pour éviter la clé
d'étranglement
ça veut dire quoi concrètement oui la
famille on est aux jeux que j'ai pas
compris non marc donnez moi je pensais
que vous aviez un terminer votre votre
liste ils disent qu'ils ont pas entendu
non aujourd'hui disent qu'ils ont pas
entendu ce que cédric leur disais c'est
les coups de pied qui mettait au sol les
débattements c'était pas pour ceux se
commet pour faire
pour contrainte à son arrestation
c'était parce qu'il étouffait il était
en train de mourir
je précise je leur dis à chaque fois que
je passe sur une antenne que cédric est
mort le 3 janvier il est mort le 3
janvier aux alentours de 10h 10h30 sur
le pavé de paris il est pas mort à
l'hôpital il était déjà mort
cliniquement quand ils arrivent à
l'hôpital il avait plus de cerveau on
arbore on a refait démarré son coeur
parce que c'était c'était c'était mieux
qui meurent à l'hôpital que sur le pavé
ça faisait ça faisait mauvais genre pour
la police c'est clairement christian
souvient que il ya eu une forme de
manipulation et voilà qu'on a caché des
choses clairement dans la mort de votre
fils selon le 2 puis 2 2 puis depuis le
début qu'il est parti de bureaux du gond
bureau j'étais le dernier le voit depuis
9h20 qu'il est parti il a eu à 9h45 je
crois qu'ils l'ont interpellé et à 10h
ou 10h15 puisque ça a duré 22 minutes et
voir plus qu'il est décédé
de ce moment là le tissu de mensonges a
commencé et là ils ont fait une belle
couverture parce que ça n'arrête pas
castaner est un menteur je le répète je
le redis au gouvernement personne ne se
bouge personne veut il a il a voulu
faire arrêter la clé d'étranglement et
comme d'habitude il a eu tous les
syndicats qui sont révolutionner et
empreint de compte il l'art permis
jusqu'au mois de septembre
voilà c'est à dire jusqu'au mois de
septembre on peut encore avoir des morts
à cause de la clé d'étranglement
voilà je suis pas d'accord mais ma
famille mes enfants mes petits enfants
ma fille ma femme on n'est pas d'accord
son épouse ait pas d'accord qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
faut arrêter la clé d'étranglement faut
arrêter le placage ventrale moi je vais
leur donner une solution puisque tous
ces cerveaux qu'on fait qu'on fait l'ena
qu'on fait tout ça il n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu' il suffit de le contrôler
et de prendre son nom son adresse
parce qu'il a donné ces documents il a
donné ses papiers il est en règle
ils ont mis une amende je crois ou deux
je sais pas s'ils ont mis des pvv j'ai
pas encore le rapport mais il a il a
donné ses papiers puisqu'ils ont donné
donc il a bien il n'a pas refusé
d'obtempérer
il a donné ses papiers donc il est en
règle après l'ont taquiné ils ont
cherché non plus et jusqu'à la faute
jusqu'à huit ans à sortir des insultes
aux au point jeux permettent à quatre
pattes et je passais exclusion et de
vulgarité
parce que c'est les mots qui ont été
dits je pas de faire une pipe voilà ce
qu'il a dit donc si la provocation elle
vient de la partie briques où elle vient
de l'apeis ça faudrait qu'on m'explique
là vous avez pris vous même qui s'en
souvient la connaissance de
l'enregistrement un produit par par le
micro ducasse de votre fils cédric à
aucun moment votre fils qu'on soit bien
clair n'a été violent madame je donne
mais demain je donne mais demain vous me
les coupe et demain il n'a jamais sorti
une grossièreté une violence de sa part
il a juste dit je vous film parce que je
vais porter plainte
vous m'avez bousculer vous m'avez
poussez vous m'avez insulté je vais
porter plainte
et quand il a dit ça eh ben ils ont
continué à rigoler voilà il ya même là
la policière qui étaient là qui a dit un
passant qui est en voiture mais laissez
nous tranquilles on a quand même bien le
droit de rigoler voilà mais elle savait
pas que dix minutes après il était mort
le gars voyez la voyez la rigolade ruche
jusqu'au elle va la rigolade
voyons où on en est aujourd'hui avec la
police alors c'est pas tout la police ya
comme ça faut pas non plus à extrapoler
on n'en veut pas la police on n'est pas
des anti policiers et dans tout etat il
faut il faut une police lui faut une
police qui soit juste pas une police qui
quand vous avez travaillé le matin vous
tuer on les défend on cache tout on
dissimule tout pour pas que vous ayez
raison mais là là ils sont pas veinard
c'est que c'est la première fois que
tout est filmé tout est filmé donc là
ils vont avoir du mal à se défendre
c'est là que nous aujourd'hui on prive
haut et fort que il faut qu'il faut que
ces gens là payent payent l'addition de
tout ce qui a été fait avant vous
demandez aujourd'hui une requalification
de l'information judiciaire
vous voilà oui on demande à ce que ça
soit volontaire et pas involontaire
c'est pas un accident c'est un mot qui
aujourd'hui on peut pas employer dans la
sphère de mon fils on peut pas dire
c'est un accident
il était coursier s'il avait eu un
accident il ya un camion qui lui sera il
y aurait roulé dessus
c'était différent c'était un accident un
accident bain professionnel parce que
c'est un métier dangereux
là c'est pas un accident professionnel
c'est un contrôle car qui aujourd'hui a
mal tourné parce que il ya eu deux trois
ou quatre personnes qu'on dit à un
moment donné on s'arrête pas on va pas
s'arrêter
il est devenu tout noir il était bleu
quand ils sont arrêtés était bleu et
respirait plus il était mort
cliniquement mort ils n'ont pomper
pomper pour essayer de réparer leurs
conneries
et quand ils ont dit ils ont ils ont
tous fait l'ont sauvé ils ont sauvé quoi
quand vous appuyez le cerveau est pas
sauvé vous êtes à légumes qu'on me dise
pas le mot on est et on l'a sauvé c'est
ce qui est employée aujourd'hui on l'a
sauvé mais qu'est-ce que mais qu'est-ce
qu'on comment on peut dire ça on l'a
sauvé ils ont rien sauver du tout il
était mort cliniquement ça faisait déjà
plus de trois ou quatre minutes que le
coeur ne battait plus qu avait plus rien
que ça brut et sans oxygène elle est où
elle est où aujourd'hui la logique de
ces gens là merci ils ont essayé de
réparer leurs bavures plus en plus
pourvus qui redémarre qu aucun des rares
merci beaucoup
christian show via père de cédric
souvient d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour avoir apporter votre
témoignage et cette réaction
à six jours du deuxième tour des
municipales on en vient ces révélations
de mediapart selon le journal la députée
laetitia via candidate aux élections
dans le 12e arrondissement de paris
aurait utilisé ses ressources
parlementaire pour mener sa campagne
électorale
une pratique proscrites à la fois par le
règlement de l'assemblée le guide de la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et le code électoral des
discussions qu aurait nié en bloc la
candidate la reine par le biais de son
avocat toujours selon mediapart et de
nouvelles révélations concernant
laetitia avia qui interviennent peu
après un camouflet pour la députée dont
la loi contre la haine en ligne a été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec didier maïsto président de sud
radio bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être
avec nous à ses côtés cyril d'allemands
chercheurs associés pour l'institut
thomas more bonsoir à vous aussi
s'il d'helmand merci d'être avec nous
première question que j'ai envie de vous
poser est ce que mediapart est
clairement devenu en france
l'antichambre de la justice et je dirais
même de la justice politique
didier maïsto bonsoir je ne crois pas
que je sais pas si mediapart est devenu
l'antichambre de la justice force est de
constater que la justice en france est
complètement grippé complètement en tout
cas le minet dans le port est ouverte et
politiques de la république française ou
de ce qu'il en reste
je vous renvoie à ce qu'a dit eliane
houlette ancienne patronne du parquet
national financier même si comme il est
d'usagé en france quand on fait un
certain nombre de révélations
on revient deux jours après où le
lendemain sur ses propres révélations en
disant que les français n'ont pas
compris qu'on a été mal compris ou que
les français étaient trop idiot
ce n'est c'est un secret de polichinelle
la justice française n'est pas
indépendante les parcs et ne sont pas
indépendants on peut observer une
célérité absolue dans certains cas et
une lenteur extrême dans d'autres donc
mediapart comme nous le faisons un sud
radio comme je lé fais dans différents
sites lanceur ou lyon capitale dont je
m'occupe un moment donné si vous ne le
faites pas c'est terrible d'ailleurs de
gaza du ramdam médiatique du battage
médiatique les affaires finissent dans
des méandres et sont complètement
enterré donc mediapart est un média de
salubrité publique parce que évidemment
malheureusement aujourd'hui la justice
est uniquement politique
voilà ce que je peux dire sur ces
ressources de façon générale par rapport
à votre question c'est lille d'allemands
sur les faits alors laetitia vient elle
dément s'est fait ces révélations de
mediapart à ce qu'elle vous ont
surprises ce genre d'affaires finalement
deviendrait-elle assez courante en
france
en fait bonsoir je pense que le problème
99% du du problème par rapport aux
instants par le modèle existant
parlementaires et les problèmes liés à
donc notamment de leur utilisation à
part les parlementaires est liée à leur
statut il n'y a pas de statut
plastiquement parlementaire et justement
comme il n'y a pas de statut n'est pas
de définition de pose et il n'y a pas de
grille indiciaire de grilles de
rémunération moi j'ai été pendant la
sphère fillon vous parlez des e-mails
pauvres sous entendu tout à l'heure
j'étais vraiment choquée par les
affirmations certains journalistes quand
ils parlaient d'emplois fictifs comment
vous les qualifier un emploi fictif à
partir du monde n'existe pas de
définition de cet emploi ccc à ses
adhérents et là en fait souvent il ya
des conclusions de genre qui s'opère au
niveau de l'utilisation des ressources
on va dire des ressources humaines
constituent des assistants
parlementaires avec un assistant
parlementaire il peut à s'occuper du
courrier il peut s'occuper d'organiser
des manifestations d'organiser des
réunions il peut s'occuper de l'agenda
mais il faut aussi à rédiger à des
questions écrites des propositions de
loi ou à des amendements donc en fait
tout dépend de tout dépend de la
définition que le parlementaire va
donner à la fonction de son assistant
parlementaire et vous n'avez jamais ce
problème avec les assistantes où les
collaborateurs de sénateurs parce qu'ils
ont à la statue donc qui dit statut dit
niveau de compétence et diddy aussi
grille indiciaire
est ce que didier maïsto du coup par
conséquent c'est vraiment ce statut des
assistants parlementaires qu'il faut
réformer puisque manifestement on l'a
déjà vu effectivement avec la sphère
fillon égard il ya un flou dans ce
domaine oui c'est un flou signalement
l'a très bien dit je vois qui connaît
bien la question c'est un flou savamment
et sciemment entretenu parce qu'en fait
ce sont des contrats de droit privé avec
de l'argent public avec un contrat de
confiance qui est uniquement qui est
unilatéral en fait un le député moi j'ai
fait ce boulot aussi peu le rompre à
tout moment et donc vous êtes un petit
peu je vais pas employer les grands mots
mais l'esclave du du député vous
dépendez son bon vouloir et allez soyons
magnanimes 90% des parts le dd députés
utilisent leur réussite leur assistant
parlementaire pour ce pour laurent blanc
bon vouloir coller des affiches vers les
campagnes électorales municipales
10 les amendements rédigés des discours
de telle sorte que souvent les députés
paraissent le mardi et le mercredi lors
des questions d'actualité mais dans la
soute
il y a les assistants parlementaires qui
font tout le boulot est entré dans une
hypocrisie générale parce que les gens
ne connaissent pas le sujet on dit on
l'a vu à l'occasion de la cuillère
fillon ont dit c'est à l'emploi fictif
mais je suis d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire si vilain emplois fictifs encore
faut-il pour pour délivrer gérer dire le
l'affectation d'emplois fictifs
encore faut-il définir ce qu'est
l'emploi quelle est sa grille indiciaire
quels sont les tenants et les
aboutissants quelles sont les fonctions
quelles sont les missions
or c'est le flou absolu et donc tout le
monde se retranche derrière cette
hypocrisie
comment voulez vous démontrer la réalité
d'un emploi si cet emploi n'est pas
défini et et c'est bien tout le problème
quant à madame alia je crois enfin en
fait on va y venir
il ya eu un camouflé comme vous l'avait
indiqué dans votre titre est dans votre
accroche sur sa loi et j'observe que
quand même
nous étions très très peu dans les
médias a donné un petit peu de la voix
il faut que ce soit neuf sages qui
rappelle ce qu'est notre constitution
j'avais imaginé que l'ensemble des
médias
fût ce un petit peu complètement révolté
par cette loi liberticide
il était de bon ton et simplement de en
aide sans faire du juridisme de seconde
de se référer à la constitution pour
dire que cette loi était insupportable
quoi que madame avia aurait plutôt
besoin d'une bonne psychanalyse elle a
dû souffrir de brimades dans sa vie
passée elle a voulu en faire une loi
générale qui a été censuré parce qu'en
france il ya une constitution il ya des
lois il ya des lois fondamentales et
morsures en tout cas ne s'est pas remise
en cause des six à rien parce qu'elle se
dit effectivement déçu par par cet
accueil de sa loi mais ne renonce pas
elle le dit dans un tweet du 18 juin
notre détermination à lutter contre le
discours de haine reste entière nous le
devons à toutes les victimes de la haine
en ligne on est un petit peu be sur gay
effectivement du débat initial cyril
d'helmand la raison de s'accrocher
effectivement 7 à cette loi des tice et
avia pour moi pas totalement tort en
fait le fond le fond du problème c'est
que la haine en ligne comment
voulez-vous juridique à la rixe et
infantile mans c'est complètement
aberrant fait intellectuellement le
sentiment de propos manifestement et
nous va dépendre de l'interprétation de
celui qui va le lire vous pouvez pas
judiciariser ce sentiment cc c'est
aberrant après on peut voilà comme dans
le meilleur des mondes deux clés on peut
pénaliser pourquoi pas l'amour
l'empathie tout tout tout tout sentiment
en fait c'était un pas de trop mais qui
à mon avis vient quand même qui vient de
loin en fait depuis des années la fin
des années 80 et début des années 90 on
a un lent grignotage des libertés
fondamentales des libertés publiques et
des droits fondamentaux pour pour être
plus précis avec une surenchère de lois
sécuritaires donc il n'y a pas vraiment
en fait d'étude d'impact d'ailleurs sur
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
multiplication de lois sécuritaires sur
la délinquance
il ya quasiment aucune preuve qu'elle
que l'impact soit réelle et là on est
sûr sur un point de bascule en fait et
d'ailleurs est assez assez étrange mais
qu'en sortir de confinement avec une
atteinte quand même très très lourde
une liberté fondamentale qui est la
liberté simplement d'aller et venir
les deux projets majeurs du gouvernement
ont été justement la loi a bien et le
projet stop qu'ovide dont la
intrinsèquement pose un problème quant
aux quant à la liberté d'expression et
liberté de communication comme la
commune a très très bien a souligné le
conseil constitutionnel et d'autres
portent atteinte intrinsèquement à la
vie privée et éventuellement s'il devait
devenir obligatoire en cas de nouvelles
pandémies également la liberté d'aller
et venir
donc moi je pense qu'elle a tort de
s'acharner
je pense que les sages ont été
d'ailleurs très précis et dont ils ont
même donné pourra finir une petite leçon
de démocratie à l'assemblée en indiquant
que le législateur avait porté atteinte
à la liberté d'expression et de
communication
une attente qui n'était pas adapté
nécessaires et proportionnées
alors le mot de la fin avec un didier un
restaurant cdti salvia est candidate aux
élections le rappel dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris ces révélations
de mediapart arrive avec ce calendrier
est effectivement intéressant à six
jours du scrutin quelles pourraient en
être les conséquences est ce que selon
vous les français sanctionneront la dea
pour la députée pour cela de toute façon
vous avez vu qu'avec sud radio que nous
avons fait un certain nombre de sondages
il semble avéré même si une élection
n'est jamais joué d'avancé que madame
hidalgo gagnera il aurait été un petit
peu je sais pas élégant de la part de
madame avia de de reconnaître que elle
se situe est elle même dans un état de
droit et que le conseil constitutionnel
avait tranché et elle continue
malheureusement à ne pas être à la
hauteur et de faire part de son humeur
et de son sentiment or quel est le cas
les l'apanage je dirais est davantage
d'un état de droit c'est de justement
par ledroit transcender tous les
sentiments individuels par la
constitution et le droit c'est la forme
la plus évoluée du vivre ensemble et je
crois que
avia ne l'a pas compris elle a dû sans
doute souffrir de brimades et de
vexations dans sa vie personnelle et ses
assistants parlementaires ont porté
plainte contre elle on verra ce que dit
la justice ils ont accusé d'homophobie
de racisme et de mots très très dur et
on voit qu'elle est un petit peu à la du
mal à percer le plafond de verre et
qu'elle essaie de faire de son cas
particulier un cas général et les sages
du conseil constitutionnel ont rappelé à
bon escient que la france demeurer un
état de droit où l'arbitraire ou et et
le sentiment personnel n'avaient pas
leur place
merci didier maïsto merci ces îles
d'allemands d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france dont quelques
instants passés avec nous nous parlerons
de la restauration et de l'hôtellerie un
secteur en souffrance à cause évidemment
de la crise du coronavirus une action
coup de poing à mener aujourd'hui à
paris et puis direction l'allemagne qui
confine au niveau local une première une
décision prise à la suite de
l'apparition d'un foyer de contamination
encore en habit russe dans un grand
abattoir
[Musique]
l'état a mis sur la table une série de
mesures pour aider le secteur 18
milliards d'euros pour le tourisme là
pour l'instant via les aides encore les
aides et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée bon ok ça parle
beaucoup mais qu'il faut il faut du
concret et les fonds de solidarité de
1500 euros et ses terrasses et des
pacotilles tout ça c'est c'est mal fait
c'est mal préparée donc comment voulez
vous que les gens s'y retrouvent le plus
dur c'est à venir et c'est là où pour
l'armement contrôler ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus
donc de toute façon on est on est dans
une impasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des féminicides aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences existait
avant leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les dos
des féminicides a plus que j'étais pas
doublé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile
groen et jamais des amiénois finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya un huis clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on écrit ce qui ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
johnny rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça faut ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur personne non non c'est pas vrai il
ya des climato sinon ce n'est pas rien à
part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
mais il ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il
ya plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un brin par une
catastrophe ou va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimistes nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense que les communes guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons ville et les demis y
en a pas des demies l'ennemi ceni
où
[Musique]
20h30 heure de paris merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france la
restauration et l'hôtellerie mise à mal
par la crise sanitaire en france les
salariés intermittents de ce secteur ont
mené une action coup de poing ce matin à
paris ils réclament un plan d'urgence
pour leur profession et s'oppose à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
à l'origine de leur colère la
possibilité de bénéficier des mesures d'
aides prévues par l'état et faute
d'avoir pu travailler
nombreux sont ceux qui n'ont pas droit à
des indemnités de chômage leur
manifestation simuler une marche funèbre
depuis l'assemblée nationale jusqu'à la
place de la concorde
une délégation devrait être reçue
prochainement par muriel pénicaud la
ministre du travail
le gouvernement a mis en place des
mesures d'urgence chose qui est bien
depuis le début du confinement depuis la
crise sanitaire
c'est bien on félicite la chose mais en
parallèle il a laissé à la marche plus
de deux millions de personnes qui sont
dans l'intermittence de l'emploi qu'on
appelle plus communément les extras de
l'hôtellerie restauration événementielle
et autres et qui n'ont aucune mesure
d'urgence tout le monde a été sauvé par
un chômage partiel et c'est pas le cas
pour nous parce que certains dépendent
d'un certain nombre d'heures par rapport
au premier volet de la réfondation
chômage quelque 910 heures n'ayant pas
les heures pas droit au chômage
simplement et donc après on demande les
minima sociaux dans certains cas on peut
avoir le rsa mais c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde
voilà et est ce que le rsa c'est un plan
d'urgence pour vivre ça c'est une
problématique ou qu'elle le gouvernement
ne répond pas mais quand même on
travaille en intermittence de l'emploi
toute l'année depuis des années au plus
haut sommet de l'état à l'elysée raison
d'assad
les ministères et administrations et
c'est notre statut qui est comme ça hein
c'est un cdi on peut pas en avoir un
passé à la manifestation tout le
personnel extra qui dépendent
l'événementiel se retrouvent
de plus en plus dans une crypte dans une
précarité extrême on demande
l'annulation de cette réforme là et que
tous les extras maître d'hôtel de la
restauration qui dépendent de
l'événementiel tous les goûts tous les
intermittents du spectacle reprennent se
retrouve dans le régime
intermittent auquel nous avons dans
lequel nous étions jusqu'en 2014 et pour
en parler nous sommes avec hassen zem
membres du collectif des précaires de
l'hôtellerie restauration événementielle
bonsoir assez naze et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur les france on vient
de vous voir vous exprimer aujourd'hui
clairement comment qualifiez vous votre
situation de catastrophique
bonsoir madame devenue catastrophique
parce que le gouvernement il a mis à la
marge de la société plus de deux
millions de personnes
la mission principale de l'état et de
les protéger
et malheureusement le gouvernement n'a
mis aucune mesure d'urgence pour
protéger toutes ces personnes au jour
d'aujourd'hui en a comme réponse que du
mépris du déni de l'ignorance de la part
du gouvernement
c'est pour cela que nous mettons toutes
nos forces afin de afin de sensibiliser
la classe politique le gouvernement pour
qu'il prenne en charge l'autre situation
clairement vous vous considérez aussi
aujourd'hui comme des laissés pour
compte c'est vrai que beaucoup de
secteurs la moitié des salariés du privé
étaient au chômage partiel
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous les laissés
pour compte
c'est cela exactement on se considère on
se considère comme étant des sous
citoyens parce que l'état comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure dans sa principale
fonction est de protéger ses citoyens
eh bien ils ont absolument rien fait le
gouvernement n'a proposé aucune aucune
solution à notre problème n'a mis aucune
mesure d'urgence sauf s'ils considèrent
le rsa comme étant une mesure d'urgence
nous par contre en a mis des
propositions sur la table
on a dernièrement qu initié avec 14
autres collectifs à
nouvelle réforme de l'assurance chômage
qu'on a mis sur la table qui est basée
sur deux études solide à savoir celles
de l'unédic et celle du sociologue
mathieu grégoire qui disent on un seul
mot que cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage est une catastrophe sociale en
coin justement elle est pour vous hassen
azem cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage
en quoi elle va particulièrement
expliquez-nous vous vous pénalisez alors
il faut vous sachiez que l'assurance
chômage dont calade deux volets 1 le
premier volet il a été actée sans
l'accord des partenaires sociaux en
novembre 2019 le gouvernement à passer
en force et à ce premier volet déjà il a
eu un impact très négatif sur les
entrants à à l'assurance chômage
sachez que chaque mois il ya plus de
vingt mille personnes qui sont éjectés
de l'assurance chômage pour insuffisance
de droit al'inverse que al'inverse il ya
200 à 300 personnes de sont indépendants
et trois cent dix missionnaires à
laquelle laquelle magnolia puis du co se
targue c'est une fierté pour elle mais
il ya vingt mille personnes qui sont
vraiment éjecté de l'assurance chômage
chaque mois je vous laisse faire le
calcul
et au jour d'aujourd'hui à plus de 400
milles personnes qui se retrouve sans le
sou s'ils ont la chance ils ont le rsa
le 1er septembre il ya le deuxième volet
qui va rentrer en jeu et ça ça touche là
le calcul de l'indemnité journalière et
là ça va être une catastrophe ça va être
dramatique parce que on va se retrouver
avec des seuils en deçà du 2 du rsa
alors le secteur de l'événementiel et le
vôtre est totalement à l'arrêt quoique
l'hôtellerie évidemment et la
restauration reprennent tout doucement
quelles solutions concrètes vous espérez
aujourd'hui la solution concrète situe
le gouvernement accepte nos
revendications on demande la même chose
que nos amis du monde du spectacle à
savoir le gel de nos indemnités
journalières qu'on ait eue nabeul une
année blanche comme nos amis du monde du
spectacle
on demande l'annulation pure et simple
de cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
on demande un moratoire sur l'assurance
chômage qu'on réunisse les experts le
plus compétent pour en parler de cette
nouvelle réforme de l'assurance chômage
et qu'on est l'humain au coeur du projet
et qu'on arrête de nous prendre pour un
tableur excel pour des chiffres qu'on
manipule
merci beaucoup à saint nazaire d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
pour évoquer votre situation
également mise à rude épreuve pendant la
crise sanitaire le personnel hospitalier
qui est à nouveau descendue dans la rue
pour un nouveau mardi de la colère un
rassemblement s'est tenu devant
l'hôpital pompidou à paris
syndicats et collectifs de soignants
réclament des revalorisations de
salaires dès embauchés une augmentation
du budget de l'hôpital public des
soignants qui se disent déçus du shaker
de la santé organisée par l'exécutif
le rapport de force plus les salariés
sont en capacité de mettre en place dans
leurs établissements à travers la grève
tout ce qu'on peut obtenir des
revalorisations
c'est pas le ségur présidée par nicole
notât et une casse sociale de première
classe c'est par là que ça se passe donc
dans la tête ça sera dans les hôpitaux
le mouvement et continue de gonfler à
paris et en province et
on veut c'est des augmentations de
salaires la revalorisation du point
d'indicé pour permettre à toutes les
catégories d'être d'avoir des
augmentations personnellement ça fait 20
ans que je travaille ici sans avoir été
augmenté sa fortune disant salaires sont
gelés
les conditions de travail déplorables on
demande c'est pas cessé des moyens des
moyens de pouvoir travailler
correctement et c'est pas le cas on
n'est pas entendu de moins en moins
puisé les plus les années passent et moi
on est entendu en fait cette opération
choc d'extinction rébellion en place
beauvau aujourd'hui les militants du
mouvement écologiste ont déversé du faux
sont devant l'entrée du ministère de
l'intérieur
certains se sont enchaînés aux grilles
le but protester contre la politique
répressive du gouvernement qui
ralentissent heureux
la prise de décision en faveur de
l'écologie
il était entouré les forces de l'ordre
ce qui ne les a pas empêchés de scander
leurs revendications et leurs slogans
rameix taxe sur les millions du
traitement
mais les ont subi ces leçons des
millions de morts ce qui va le boulier
chinois
m
ça y est
une action pour dénoncer notamment les
violences policières écouter exception
événement a choisi la désobéissance
civile pourquoi parce qu'on estimait que
les pétitions les tribunes il y en a
beaucoup déjà et puis que souvent ça ne
marchait pas il fallait des actions un
peu plus spectaculaires ont été dégoûtés
par les violences policières
ça dure depuis 18 mois dans une
démocratie c'est pas normal et ça dure
et ça dure et là ça vient de reprendre
avec la sortie du confinement
donc premièrement ou dénoncer ça et dire
que si on apaise pas la société on ne va
pas arriver à faire des réformes qui
sont nécessaires par rapport aux
changements climatiques et à défendre la
biodiversité est en pleine polémique sur
les violences policières et les
comportements racistes au sein des
forces de l'ordre revenons sur la sphère
myriam sakhri nous avons rencontré
l'avocate de la famille de la gendarme
qui demande depuis deux ans la
réouverture de l'enquêté sur la mort de
la jeune femme
elle avait été retrouvée morte à son
domicile de fonction en 2011
luis carballo avec cyrielle benavides
bulbul un gendarme dans la caserne
delfosse à lyon myriam sakhri 32 ans
passent en 2011 quelques mois au sein du
centre d'opérations et de renseignement
de la gendarmerie le corg dans ce
service qui reçoit 24 heures sur 24 les
appels d'urgence passé par le 17
myriam relève une succession d'insultés
de moqueries et d'agissements de la part
de plusieurs de ses collègues envers des
usagers d'origine étrangère lorsque des
gens en danger
appeler le 17 eh bien les gendarmes se
permettait de raccrocher au nez d'usagé
parce qu'ils avaient un accent étranger
de faire des remarques racistes et
finalement de ne pas faire leur travail
de ne pas porter secours correctement et
d'avoir un comportement discriminatoire
ces agissements devenant systématique
elle en averti sa hiérarchie mais en
vain face à l'inaction de ses supérieurs
myriam décide de déposer une plainte
pénale
elle n'y parviendra jamais à la rendez
vous le lundi matin pour déposer la
plainte pénale
au cabinet de son avocat
et le samedi elle est retrouvée morte
dans sa chambre d'une balle avec une
trajectoire descendante dans le ventre
aucun gendarme
aucune famille de gendarmes aucun des
voisins l'a entendue dans la nuit du
vendredi au samedi 24 septembre 2011
la détonation c'est l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie nationale lit
ggn qui prend en charge l'enquète elle
conclue rapidement que myriam sakhri
s'est suicidé pour des raisons
personnelles
la famille de la victime conteste
immédiatement les faits et demande à ce
que l' enquête soient reprises par la
police judiciaire
de son côté le procureur en charge de la
faire affirme que l' enquête a été menée
de façon indépendante
il n'y a jamais de croisement entre les
deux institutions
l' enquête a été menée dans la plus
grande clarté de manière contradictoire
par l'inspection générale de la
gendarmerie nationale
tout ce qui pouvait être fait l'a été la
famille n'avait pas exercé de recours
pour demander de nouvelles auditions
en 2018 le nouvel avocat de la famille
demande au parquet de lyon de rouvrir le
dossier en raison de l'apparition de
nouveaux éléments et de zones d'ombré
qui subsistent dans ce cas précis où on
dénonce des pratiques internes à la
gendarmerie où les jeunes et sur place
une semaine avant pour enquêter sur ces
pratiques discriminatoires et conclu
circulez ya rien à voir
comment peut-on imaginer que ces mêmes
services qui enquêtent sur le décès de
sept gendarmes
comment dans ces conditions là peut tout
donner le moindre crédit la moindre
légitimité à l'issue de cette
instruction qui a duré un certain nombre
d'années on ne peut pas nous avons
toutes les raisons de croire et même
d'avoir la certitude en ce qui concerne
la famille de la gendarme sacré qu'elle
a été suscitée
autrement dit qu'elle a été tuée le
magistrat a précisé qu'au moment de sa
mort en plus des accusations de racisme
au sein de la gendarmerie
myriam sakhri enquêter sur la corruption
de notables lieu
né et des affaires de violences
sexuelles sur mineurs la crise du corona
virus en allemagne déjà concerné par un
recond finement local berlin on annonce
un second cela fait suite à l'apparition
d'un important foyer de contamination
dans un abattoir le récit de florian
lambert alors que le déconfinement se
poursuit en europe l'allemagne est
contrainte à 2 quarantaine locales après
la région de lisbonne au portugal
c'est l'ensemble du canton voisin de
warendorf et celui de goûteurs slot qui
sont concernés par un recond finement
pour ce dernier
lundi soir les autorités locales ont
annoncé que mille cinq cent cinquante
trois personnes avaient été contaminées
par le cobp et 19 dans un grand abattoir
de la région quelques 7000 personnes ont
été placées en quarantaine
vingt-et-une autres sont hospitalisées
dont six en soins intensifs et ce mec
est le but est de calmer la situation et
d'étendre les tests pour établir si le
virus s'est diffusé dans la population
via les salariés de l'abattoir tennis
seront confinement prévu dans un premier
temps jusqu'au 30 juin contre 1 de
nouveau ce canton à une limitation
stricte des contacts à la fermeture des
bardes cinéma et des musées ainsi qu'à
l'interdiction des activités de loisirs
dans les espaces fermés
ces mesures drastiques interviennent à
dix jours des vacances scolaires dans un
canton qui compte 360 mille habitants
mais les autorités allemandes se veulent
optimistes concernant la menace d'une
deuxième vague
je pense qu'une deuxième vague peut
toujours arriver et elle peut bien sûr
survenir en allemagne je suis cependant
très optimiste parce que les gens savent
que s'ils continuent de se comporter en
faisant attention
et puisque les événements de grande
ampleur ne sont toujours pas autorisés
nous pourrons éviter cette deuxième
vague d'artistes phares et tevez wayne
cole l'allemagne compte à ce jour plus
de 190 mille cas pour 8969 décès et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
berlin avec yoga branson membres de la
chambre des représentants de berlin fdc
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir young bronson merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on a
toujours présenté l'allemagne comme un
bon élève comment on explique ce regain
liés aux coronavirus c'est l'effet le
plus large et le plus peuplé de l'union
européenne qui a toujours des foyers des
régions où le virus existent un virus ne
se répande pas et également dans le même
toute une région et on ne peut pas
définir deux régions pandémique alors
1re confinement locale alors qu'on est
en plein déconfinement d un petit peu à
contresens est effectivement vous
comprenez que ça puisse inquiéter faire
peur ou alors il faut tout simplement
relativiser ont réagi parce que
justement on veut éviter la contagion
c'est le député la saison des vacances
cela représente un gros problème
l'impact sera sur le voyage tourisme
personne ne va se rendre dans une région
il ya un nouveau confinement du à la
copie 19 n'est jamais qu'une des
conditions d'hygiène ne sont pas du tout
à la hauteur
la plupart des travailleurs viennent de
l'étranger et vif dans une grande
promiscuité c'est un milieu idéal pour
la contamination est ce que justement
vous estimez aujourd'hui finalement que
ces régions un petit peu de monde et
trop tôt leurs déconfinement un gala
merkel on se souvient la chancelière
était plutôt prudente mais les régions
effectivement ont fait pression pour le
déconfinement toujours difficile de dire
ce qui va arriver à la vis en matière de
pandémie
certaines personnes je prédis une
seconde vague de la bande haut
mais nous n'avons pas encore connu cela
on ne sait pas quelles mesures seront
nécessaires la semaine prochaine où les
semaines d'après vous le disiez un coup
dur effectivement quelques jours des
grandes vacances
ce sont des régions particulièrement
fréquentée par les touristes normalement
en été normalement on est éblouissant de
personnes se rendent dans ces régions
plus rurales ou visitent le pays et dans
ces régions aucun fumeur alors même
qu'on ne peut plus vraiment se rendre à
l'étranger
les touristes ne vont pas venir tout et
cela va représenter un lourd coût pour
l'industrie touristique
alors ce canton a confiné à l'est les
causes d'un foyer de contamination dans
un abattoir ce n'est pas la première
fois que ces lieux sont exposés ils le
sont particulièrement effectivement
elles sont particulièrement frappés les
conditions d'hygiène je voulais qu'ils
ne sont pas très bonnes et les
contractuels ne sont pas payés à l'heure
mais à l'unité de travail la plupart du
temps ce sont des étrangers qui vivent
dans des logements très étroit c'est
donc un milieu propice à la
contamination de n'importe quel virus de
tous
l'industrie de la viande est soutenue
par des financements d'état et que font
comment réagissent les autorités
justement face à ce que vous décrivez
les autorités réagissent différemment en
fonction des régions des länder les
régions en allemagne sont assez autonome
la région de poméranie par exemple à
créer des centres de test
qui seront fermées sauf deux à berlin là
où je vis des nouvelles amendes seront
imposées aux personnes qui ne porte pas
des masques dans les transports publics
et dans les boutiques donc en fonction
de la région
les réactions sont très différentes en
fonction de la force de la puissance de
la pandémie
une chose est sûre l'allemagne sort
plutôt voit la vaillante de cette crise
du conrad un virus un des taux de
mortalité les plus faibles d'europe are
système hospitalier qui s'est révélé
plutôt bien équipé des thèses des
masques vous êtes d'accord pour dire
clairement aujourd'hui que l'allemagne a
extrêmement bien géré la crise du
coronavirus où on est un petit peu trop
dithyrambiques
effectivement la gestion de crise a été
efficace mais je pense qu'il ya quelques
années je travaillais dans un hôpital
horani il faut dire que en médecine
toute chose est optionnelle et rien
n'est obligatoire
même la meilleure des préparations ne
devra préparer quelqu'un à inattendue
dont on ne sait pas comment la situation
va se développer de toute façon merci
jorgensen membres de la chambre des
représentants de berlin f des d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les faire cédric
joue via la famille de cet homme de 42
ans mort des suites d'une interpellation
en janvier à paris demande emmanuel
macron d'agir contre les violences
policières
et puis nous parlerons de la crise du
coronavirus dans l'hexagone si des
chiffres quotidiens ne cesse de
s'améliorer le constat reste tout même
inquiétant la communauté scientifique
estime de façon unanime que presse
coronavirus fera son retour à l'automne
en europe mais aussi en france
[Musique]
on
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent le faire croire vouloir
à la réécrire pour faire oublier les
échecs ne permet pas de comprendre ce
qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi deux de profession est
ce qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente vers une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe haye il ya un tournant et
on refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rencontre que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis plus
nice par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck ça que ça
veut dire
facile à lire ça si la comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
si on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des signes ici
d'aujourd'hui en france les coûts et les
violences existait avant leur
confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre l'état turler
d'eau de féminicide a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté forcément on
n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile vaud
n'est jamais des âmes et loi finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en a huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences
de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 23
juin à cette reprise cédric joue via
indiqué aux policiers qui l'étouffé
résultats d'une expertise rendue
publique aujourd'hui
ce livre est mort à la suite d'un
contrôle policier début janvier à paris
des policiers désormais sous la menace
d'une mise en examen la famille de la
victime réclame alors suspension et les
actions du gouvernement contre les
violences policières
alors que cette affaire relance le débat
faut-il interdire le placage ventrale et
la clé d'étranglement
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face la
direction générale de la santé rappelle
que le virus continue de circuler sur le
territoire une école parisienne a été
contrainte de fermer ses portes après la
détection de deux cas aujourd'hui
le spectre d'une deuxième vague reste
bien présent malgré des chiffres pour
l'instant encourageant donald trump se
dit prêt à rencontrer nicholas maduro
bien que le président américain a
précisé que cette rencontre servirait à
négocier un départ pacifique du pouvoir
vont pouvoir en cette entrevue avec le
chef d'état vénézuélien un renversement
de stratégie
le locataire de la maison blanche est il
en train de prendre ses distances avec
erwan un bois d'auch telle est la
question
en russie vladimir poutine s'est adressé
à la nation cet après midi plus d'un
mois après le déconfinement qui a
commencé le 12 mai dernier le président
a dressé le bilan préliminaire de la
lutte contre le coran navires us et
aborder la situation économique
le défilé de la victoire aura par
ailleurs bien lieu ce mercredi au lieu
du 9 mai en raison de la pandémie
coronavirus
[Musique]
retour donc sur la sphère cédric
souvient on a appris à la garde à vue de
quatre fonctionnaires de police pendant
son interpellation ce père de famille a
cligné j'étouffe à sept reprises
les faits remontent au 3 janvier 2020 au
bord de seine à paris ce livreur de 42
ans est victime d'une fracture du larynx
après une interpellation il décède deux
jours plus tard à l'hôpital
des vidéos tournées par la victime ont
conduit la justice à placer les quatre
policiers mis en cause en garde à vue
une information judiciaire est ouverte
pour homicide involontaire ses avocats
dénoncent les méthodes d'arrestation de
la police comme vous le savez comme vous
l'entendez chaque jour les syndicats de
police exerce une pression politique qui
est on peut dire le terme
lamentable et qui n'est pas à la hauteur
de du fonctionnement d'un état de droit
des fonctionnaires des syndicats de
police ne devrait pas demander à ce que
la justice ne fasse pas son travail elle
ne devrait pas demander aux pouvoirs
politiques et notamment au ministère de
l'intérieur de ne pas changer des
techniques mortels vous l'avez vu la clé
d'étranglement avait été interdite par
monsieur castanet récemment à la suite
de l'intervention des fonctionnaires de
police et de la des syndicats de police
avec de nombreuses manifestations dont
certaines sont illégales on a un
franchissement de l'égalité par des
syndicats de police qui tente de
maintenir ces techniques qui tue chaque
jour
donc nous le disons clairement c'est
bien une clé d'étranglement et c'est
bien un plaquage ventrale qui ont tué
cédric chouïa et qui ont tué d'autres
personnes en france beaucoup de
personnes sont morts du fait de ces
techniques et pas qu'en france aux états
unis et ailleurs
il faut instamment et maintenant que ces
techniques ne soient plus utilisés parce
que sinon fait aussi prendre un risque
aux fonctionnaires de police qui les
utilisent en terme de poursuite
judiciaire et notamment devant les
assises
alors faut-il interdire le placage
ventrale et la clé d'étranglement c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
david guiraud porte parole jeunesse la
france insoumise bonsoir david guiraud
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés jean
mais si un membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national
bonsoir à vous aussi jean messia merci
d'être avec nous alors vous venez de
l'entendre un des avocats de la famille
je trouve ya a livré ce matin un
véritable réquisitoire contre le placage
mantra des la clé d'étranglement des
techniques qualifiés dont mortel un
parent arié alimi
il appelait tout simplement voilà pour
leur interdiction totale vous êtes
d'accord avec ça david guiraud
oui mais vous savez moi je suis content
qu'on débatte de ça aujourd'hui avec
jean beitia parce que ça va peut-être
être l'occasion de remettre certaines
pendules à l'heure sur cette histoire
cédric souvient il est mort le 5 janvier
et vous avez un jean blaise yake disait
le 7 janvier vous dresser son twitter il
le disait j'ai encore l'image
deux jours après la mort d'un homme je
vous laisse apprécier l'humanité de ce
message il dijon mais sièges parce que
c'est tout le problème qui va nous être
posée aujourd'hui en insultant et en se
rebellant contre la police nationale
alors qu'elle ne faisait que son travail
que son boulot
cédric joue bien a été à l'origine du
drame alors moi je tiens à dire déjà
faut pas avoir de coeur pour dire ça une
famille deux jours après la perte d'un
proche mais surtout pas de cerveau parce
que les enquêtes de mediapart l'a montré
récemment cédric souvient il a répété
ses décors parc
le mauvais temps avant de mourir d'une
fracture du larynx les policiers
disaient dans leurs premières
dépositions que souvient avait fait
trébucher les policiers au sol et qu'il
est mort après le menottage ils ne
disent pas que dans un contrôle qui a
duré douze minutes pas une fois cédric
joue via n'a montré un signe de danger
physique envers les policiers
ils ne disent pas que la première un
joueur qui est lancé c'est celle des
policiers
excusez moi pour les jeunes mais c'est
un policier qui dit vous croyez pas que
je vous sucer la [ __ ] à cédric souvient
et que c'est un policier qui pousse
notamment cédric s'ouvrir à faire un
outrage puisque c'est d'actions dia dit
pauvre type mais le policier lui sert
formulées pour être sûr que c'est un
outrage et l'embarqué mais tout ça moi
d'une certaine manière je vais vous le
dire ça me rassure parce que la vérité
est en train d'émerger et surtout moi je
pense que les français n'aiment pas les
gens qui n'ont ni coeur ni cerveau de
raison pour laquelle à mon avis avec des
gens comme jean bessière dans leurs
rangs le rassemblement national jeunes
les petits grains suis tout de même ravi
de dire aux au mystère mais je dis parce
que oui c'est pas le boulot aux
policiers et pour finir là contrairement
à ce que dit monsieur messia nous les
policiers ce jour là ils n'ont pas fait
leur boulot ils ont tué un homme et il
se serait bien un jour dans le pays qu
on ouvre ce débat là ce qui n'est pas un
argument de délai en ce moment ici
d'agde hérault
alors justement jean messia david weir
au monde et que vous avez eu des mots
durs au lendemain voilà de ceux de sept
morts aujourd'hui avec ces
enregistrements qui émergent ces
éléments nouveaux est ce que vous
regrettez précisément vos propos des
propos sont pas fous ils sont très
justes c'est à dire qu'en réalité le le
problème de monsieur guy roux et de la
france insoumise
c'est qu'il croit que la police c'est
une sorte de paillasson en fait qui
mérite que de se faire insulter de se
faire caillasser
sans répondre parce que mélenchon et ses
amis considère effectivement que les
forces de l'ordre sont des punching ball
qui sont là pour qu'on s'essuie dessus
et sur lesquels on peut se dérouler
comme quoi c'est pas ma pensée moi c'est
pas ma conception des choses si vous
voulez quand on est poli avec la police
quand on est correcte avec la police la
police est correcte avec vous moi je
quand je suis arrêté par la police
ou quand mes enfants font l'objet d'une
arrestation par la police pour contrôler
leur identité
je dis pas à mes enfants d'insulter les
paie les policiers et de refuser de 2,2
de présenter leurs documents
je ne suis pas en train de justifier la
mort de quelqu'un je veux juste dire que
effectivement la police dans un état
républicain et là une gradation de
moyens d'intervention qui va quand les
individus sont polis de rien du tout
jusque là lorsque les individus sans
jusqu'à lorsque les individus sont armés
de la possibilité d'utiliser leurs armes
à feu parce que c'est l'exercice du
monopole de la violence légitime décrit
par bel air en cause et entre entre ces
deux extrêmes il y a effectivement tout
un tas de techniques pour maîtriser des
individus qui se rebelle ou qui outrage
moi je veux que david guiraud nous
explique comment fait un policier
lorsqu'il est dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions qu'il demande une pièce
d'identité qui se fait taper dessus
qui se fait cracher dessus qu'il se sait
ce qu'il doit faire et c'est de rester
l'armé au pied
en disant vous avez raison monsieur ou
est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils exercent la loi
parce que si vous voulez tout les joues
les ordres qu'on constate dans notre
société
tous les crimes la croiser
l'accroissement de la criminalité de la
délinquance qu'on constate de notre
société c'est parce que la police est
bien dans son rôle et de monsieur
dernier des idéologies portait pas
monsieur monsieur guiraud qui en
l'occurrence entend qu'idéologue lui n'a
pas de cervelle
il ne fait qu'appliquer une idéologie
propre regarder la bible dans votre
réponse en effet et pas sur les seins
sont amis sur des faits non mais sur les
faits cédric souvient il a craché sur
quelqu'un il avait une arme cédric joue
via il méritait la mort c'est simplement
moi ça prend c'est vraiment dire et vous
attendez là mais je vous ai laissé par
me poser de questions réponses le fait
d' interpeller quelqu'un ça mérite la
mort vous pensez pas qu un problème
quand quelqu'un meurt à la suite d'un
contrôle routier oui mais est-ce juste
non mais attendez jamais parfaitement
raison alexandre monsieur monsieur je
vais vous le dire monsieur messia je
vais vous le dire très honnêtement vous
voulez mettre une chape de plomb sur la
question des violences policières c'est
votre avis moi je pense qu'on rend pas
service aux policiers en faisant ça
j'assume de vous dire j'assume de vous
dire mais je la soumettrai prophète mans
si c'est ça être un idéologue je veux
bien à lettres entre un idéologue
j'assume de dire que lorsqu un homme
meurt à la suite d'un contrôle routier
il ya un problème et il ya un problème
dans la manière dont ça s'est passé il
ya un problème dans la manière dont les
policiers ont de danse que les policiers
ont dit dans leurs dépositions
parce qu'ils n'ont rien dit à part qu'il
serait soit disant qu'il aurait tomber
qui serait tombée et qu'il aurait dans
sa chute entrer quelqu'un c'est ça la
facture de la rixe qui s'est fait ça moi
je n'y crois pas et il ya un problème
parce que à vous la refusez que la
police soit exemplaire on la rend
médiocre je suis pas pour lui pour une
police médiocre je leur en parle vous
êtes mobile olicier je ne trouve pas
attendez je vais finir ma crainte et ça
c'est pas faire de l'idéologie je veux
que la police de ce pays soit aimé
qu'elle soit respectée
mais c'est pas on est
je n'ai pas aimé et lima je voudrais
vous faire réagir sur les propos de
christian show via le père de cédric
joue via qui a justement précisément
interpellé emmanuel macron il nous a
demandé d'agir
monsieur matheron faut arrêter la
guérite règlement parce que vous êtes un
meurtrier si vous continuez à la laisser
vivre
voilà le cri d'étranglement c'est un
assassinat hier il n'y a pas d'autre mot
et si vous en tant que chef de l'état
vous continuez à dire que le pacage
ventrale et la clé c'est un besoin pour
un contrôle d'identité pour un permis de
conduire pour une plaque d'identité nous
plaques d anima situation si vous ça
vous le permettez vous êtes mon club des
assassins aussi la vidéo on entendait
jean luc mélenchon il ya quelques jours
dire il faut en substance des vers mais
la police vous partagez cet avis de jean
luc mélenchon bien sûr mais moi je pense
qu'on a surtout besoin de réfléchir à
comment les policiers maintenant leurs
interventions d'ailleurs c'était ce sont
des fonctionnaires d'un service public
je pense qu'on a le droit de se
questionner sur comment fonctionne un
service public dans notre pays la clé
d'étranglement elle n'est plus enseignée
dans les gendarmeries et dans les
prisons les prisonniers sont pas moins
dangereux
ils sont pas moins difficiles à
contrôler que des citoyens lors d'un
contrôle routier
donc c'est qu'on peut faire autrement
hélas regarde il ait bien dans les
prisons pour y aller est la seule chose
que dit la famille c'est que c'est une
technique qui tue moi pour moi en tant
que citoyen engagé
je n'ai pas envie qu'on utilise dans les
résidents dans le panel des
interpellations
elle en parle pas de quelqu'un qui vous
charge avec un pistolet on parle d'un
contrôle routier
eh ben on utilise des techniques qui tue
si c'est trop difficile à admettre
eh ben c'est qu'on a un problème moi je
vous le dis en norvège allait interdite
7,7 clé d'étranglement
elle est déconseillée au royaume uni
vous avez parfois dans certains pays des
clé d'étranglement qui sont respiratoire
qui sont interdites
parfois aussi des clé d'étranglement
sanguine les simples techniques qui sont
autorisés mais on peut faire autrement
c'est pas vrai qu'on peut pas venir mais
tient prête à faire effectivement
persiste en france et comme la nbdl
maintenant le pays européens et ça n'est
pas en france brute si quelqu'un n'a pas
envie de tester la clé d'étranglement
il a qu'a tout simplement obtempéré à la
police
nous sommes dans une république
démocratique pas dans une dictature
défendu par des pantins macoutes
donc il faut respecter nos forces de
l'ordre qui ont une profonde légitimité
démocratique car elles ont reçu le
mandat populaire de faire respecter la
loi si on n'est pas d'accord il avoir
été maltraités ou injustement traités eh
bien il faut déposer plainte
j'agis les moeurs franchement mais
laissez moi parler je vous ai laissé
parler une heure vous laisser parler
maintenant
franchement je pense que la police en
france est infiniment moins dangereuse
pour la population que certaines
immigrations qui par le terrorisme et le
crime font couler beaucoup plus de sens
dans notre pays que la police voilà donc
si vous voulez le problème moi je n'ai
pas de problème qui bien sûr que tout
mort et voguerez table la question n'est
pas là bien sûr que on peut pas se
réjouir si vous voulez de la mort d'un
homme
mais le problème c'est que si on veut
pas mettre le doigt dans l'engrenage
dans un engrenage qui peut être mortelle
dans tout et vous ne citiez les exemples
du monde monsieur giraud dans aucun pays
au monde
si vous insultez la police si vous
caillassé la police il vous crachez sur
la police est bien la police va vous
maîtrisez et elle va yeux sur ses
ambitions pour beaucoup me mettrais
voilà donc si vous avez envie d'avoir de
problème il faut obtempéré maintenant si
vous voulez tester et agressivement les
clé d'étranglement et les tasers et tous
les moyens dont les polices dont les
policiers disposent pour maîtriser
quelqu'un est bien à lisier savon sans
m'en vais écouter sur leur jeu que l'on
doit jouer le président pardonnez moi on
va écouter william bourdon à un autre
avocat de la famille shaw via présent ce
matin à cette conférence de presse les
mots sont assez dures écoutez nous
lançons un appel au calme
nous lançons un appel à la
responsabilité de chacun et nous lançons
évidemment un appel à la responsabilité
de ceux qui sont les plus responsables
dans ce pays c'est à dire le président
de la république et le gouvernement
nous sommes dans un moment charnière
dans l'histoire de notre pays
bien sûr que la france n'est pas les
états unis mais la france se rapproche
des états unis elle se rapproche à la
fois par la persistance de ces violences
policières par les logiques de dénis qui
accompagnent de façon mécanique la
commission par un certain nombre
d'agents publics de violences policières
sur la voie publique est les mots sont
assez dures tout de même jean messia le
déni qui accompagnent de façon mécanique
la commission d'un certain nombre de
violences policières par des agents pour
vous il n'y a aucun fait de racisme dans
la police écoutez moi je crois que si
effectivement il y a des morts suite à
des interpellations
ce n'est ni par racisme au sein de la
police ni de manière volontaire c'est à
dire que la mort tragique et malheureuse
de cédric joue via je ne pense pas si
vous voulez que les policiers se sont
dit eh bien on va lui faire ça pour le
tuer le jeu je précise simplement à vos
téléspectateurs que lorsque ces riches
ou via été plaqué au sol il a
effectivement dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'il ait tout fait mais ça a duré 22
secondes alors faire le parallèle avec
georges floyd qui dondon l'étranglement
a duré huit minutes profiter si vous
voulez d'un fait divers tout aussi
tragique aux états unis pour nous
expliquer que en france la police est
raciste et que la police est criminel
moi je dénonce totalement sa la police
fait un travail difficile et la
criminalité c'est pas les policiers la
criminalité c'est ce contre quoi se
battent les policiers au jour le jour
accompagné des brigades d'interventions
policières dans certains quartiers ou
dans certains endroits où dans certains
publics et vous rêvez vous verrez à quoi
les policiers sont confrontés
une fois que vous aurez vu ça vous
viendrez me dire si les policiers ont
des spécialisations effective à égal
monsieur messier à moi j'ai vécu toute
ma vie en seine saint denis je sais ce
que c'est vous vous habitez à paris
c'est peut-être pas peut-être que vous
aimez écouter une chose simple écoute et
une chose simple pour vous n'y a pas de
problème en fait ça va tout va bien y a
pas de racisme y à pas durant ces
planètes unies et moi je vous dis une
chose
pardon
je ne me contente pas d'une situation où
un bep service public dysfonctionne
parce que j'estime qu'il dysfonctionne
je ne me contente pas d'une situation où
vous avez certains officiers de police
qui ont une vision médiocre de leur
travail et dans ce cas là mais vous avez
la visée est la différence entre parler
aujourd'hui je vous réponds la
différence entre vous et moi c'est que
jeter l'opprobre sur toute l'institution
non non je ne jette sirianni pro-vie
brebis galeuses pardon je je je veux
donc c'est pas une question de brebis
galeuses bien sûr que tous les policiers
sont pas racistes qui a dit sa personne
je vous dis juste que quand je vois des
images à l'ile-saint-denis à l'île saint
denis des policiers sont surpris par une
vidéo amateur en train de proférer des
injures racistes à quelqu'un tic et
arabes
d'accord et vous avez un commissaire à
côté qui ne dit rien
que se serait-il passé s'il y avait
plein d'idées ou rien il y aurait eu
impunité de la même manière que monsieur
chouf daegu cds
ce qui a choqué c'est tout le monde
s'est dit mais qu'est ce que se
serait-il passé s'il n'y avait pas eu
les vidéos
la version au nom des eaux pour moi oui
mes derniers mots de david guiraud
foulée qui est la confiance le problème
aujourd'hui c'est très policiers sont
assermentés c'est normal qu'il soit
assermenté
mais quand vous renvoyer la parole d'un
citoyen par exemple celle de la famille
de chevaux via ou autres qui ne
disposent pas des vidéos à ce moment-là
à celle d'un fonctionnaire assermenté
vous êtes perdant donc pour que la
situation soit mieux que ça s'améliore
c'est simple il faut que la police soit
réformé que certaines techniques qui tue
soit interdite et que après on peut
avoir la discussion sur les moyens
merci d'un fait divers à partir d'un
fait divers vous jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble de la série 4 2 merci jean
messia merci beaucoup merci également à
la ville gayraud d'avoir été avec nous
avoir accepté de ce face-à-face merci
le coronavirus à présent l'immunité
collective est insuffisante pour
empêcher une deuxième vague en france le
conseil scientifique alerte en tout cas
sur un retour extrêmement probable de
l'épidémie à l'automne
la france n'a donc pas fini avec le kobe
de 19 selon eux alors pour mieux
surveiller son évolution
les experts qui accompagne le
gouvernement depuis le début de la crise
préconise de conserver des données de
santé recueillies tout au long de
l'épidémie à des fins de recherche de
suivi épidémiologique est alors comment
éviter donc cette fameuse seconde vague
concr à tous pour benjamin david o
infectiologue à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches le meilleur
moyen est de tester massivement et
d'isoler les malades
ces foyers il faut finalement sont
félicités parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle il ya plus de 151 de mémoire
cluster identifiés en france
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
était capable d'empêcher le virus de se
propager la plus grande ampleur
notamment au niveau des départements et
des régions est de faire en sorte
d'avoir les conditions d'une deuxième
vague au sens de la première c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on parle de deuxième
bague il faut comprendre qu'on parle des
malades à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui les malades à l'hôpital sont
extrêmement rares ya très peu de
nouvelles entrées à l'hôpital parce que
justement on arrive à empêcher ces
malades de faire défendre sévère puisque
on diagnostique chez des gens souvent
jeunes et son appel peau si certains ont
peu ou pas de symptômes et qu'on isole
immédiatement et l'objectif comme l'a
rappelé le président de metz c'est de
détecter massivement pour pouvoir
bloquer les chaînes de transmission en
isolant les cas qui sont contaminés sur
le plan du
bilan du coup on avait besoin d'hexagone
le nombre de cas graves en réanimation
poursuit sa baisse avec 683 malades soit
19 de moins par rapport à hier
selon la direction générale de la santé
la france enregistre 57 morts liés aux
kobe 19 dans les hôpitaux ces dernières
24 heures au total 29 mille sept cent
vingt personnes sont mortes depuis le
début de l'épidémie
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jérôme marty médecin généraliste
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre bonsoir jérôme a dit
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france tout d'abord votre opinion
sur cette deuxième vague qu'on semble
maintenant nous présenter comme quasi
inéluctable en tout cas pour l'automne
écoutez je crois que rien inéluctable
personne n'est sûr de rien ce qu'on sait
c'est que le virus est parmi nous que le
virus circule pour l'instant ils ne
trouvent pas de solution pour tout d'un
coup donné de gros cluster comme cela
s'est produit il ya quelques semaines
nous sommes en fait revenu dans la
situation de novembre et décembre avec
un virus qui etc et sans qui contaminent
des jeunes des actifs qui font des
formes peu aussi symptomatique ou
asymptomatiques
mais il ne contamine pas fort
heureusement de patients âgés et à
risque parce que les mesures barrières
sont prises en particulier dans les
ehpad en particulier dans les hôpitaux
en particulier dans les foyers de
personnes âgées et dans les grands
magasins dans les lieux confinés les
gens portent des masques c'est ce qu'il
faut faire et puis forte heureusement
grâce à la saison dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons les gens sont dehors et on
sait qu'il ya moins de risque en plein
air pour une diffusion de masse de ce
virus si je vous comprends bien ça veut
dire selon ongles le virus n'est pas
spécialement moins virulent qu'il n'est
pas parti comme le prédisait le
professeur out à l'époque avec la saison
mais tout simplement voilà is here que
là bas bruit parce que
il ya ces gestes barrière c'est ce que
vous nous expliquer ce qu'on a appris
avec avec avec cette affection qu on a
appris à connaître puisqu'il ya encore
il ya quatre cinq mois ne savait rien ce
qu'on a appris c'est que c'est une
infection qui se développe en les murs
c'est à dire c'est pas tellement il a
fait sur une affection qui va se
développer à l'extérieur tous les
clusters tous les points de départ
important de cette épidémie se sont
produits donnent des zones confinées
donc ce sont ceux sommes dès l'instant
où l'on porte les masques et où l'on
sait où le moulin seront respectés les
gestes barrière ou onéreux ou anr les
pièces on ouvre les fenêtres
il ya moins de risques diffusion et puis
comme mieux encore une fois les gens
respectent quand même en grande partie
les mesures barrières le virus ne trouve
pas de solution pour se développer mais
par contre ils continuent à bas bruit a
circulé et a contaminé mais
principalement des gens jeunes donc il
est parmi nous ils ne diffusent pas de
façon grave
maintenant quand la saison froide va
arriver quand il quand les gens vont
rentrer et si en plus ils auront une
certaine lassitude quant au respect des
gestes-barrières là viendra le danger
alors justement les scènes qu'on a vu à
paris le jour de la fête de la musique
ces jeunes agglutinés en dansant son
masque ça veut dire quoi selon vous
voulez craignent et ses conséquences
dans quinze jours oui écoutez c'est une
sorte de bêta test c'est une sorte de
test grandeur nature est important par
rapport à la capacité de ce virus a
diffusé on va voir d'ici 14 15 jours
s'il y a des conséquences
il faut espérer que non parce qu'encore
une fois c'était à l'extérieur
maintenant on sait que ce virus diffusé
par contact proche et prolongé aussi que
lorsque l'on chante ou que l'on hurle on
aérosols is beaucoup donc s'il y avait
au milieu de cette foule des gens qui
sont porteurs du virus
ils peuvent avoir contaminé d'autres
personnes c'est une évidence des
responsabilités de grands sportifs par
exemple un novak djokovic qui d'ailleurs
dit regretter profondément d'avoir
organisé ce fameux tournoi novak
djokovic testé positif ça veut dire
selon vous qu'il ya une forme de
relâchement tout de même dans les dents
les esprits et aujourd'hui l'épidémie
semble loin dans la tête de la plupart
des gens écoutez c'est difficile de
respecter ces fameux gestes-barrières de
changer nos vies pendant des semaines et
des semaines et des semaines et donc
donne des moments comme ça festifs comme
la fête de la musique on ne peut voir un
certain relâchement maintenant ce que
l'on doit observer c'est que dans les
grands magasins dans les hôpitaux dans
les ehpad dans d'autres lieux
on doit reconnaître que les gestes
barrières sont respectés maintenant des
transports en commun aussi mais ce sont
des lieux au souvent le port du masque
est obligatoire peut-être faut-il garder
cette obligation pour un certain nombre
de lieux et puis je rejoins mon confrère
était sur votre antenne juste juste
avant moi il faut surtout tester tester
tester testé massivement souvent
aléatoirement pour savoir comment ceux
ci auraient dû circulent à quel taux
afin de savoir si oui ou non il y à une
augmentation de sa propagation
on a beaucoup louent l allemagne 1 pour
sa bonne gestion de l'exquise
aujourd'hui l'allemagne reconfirme alors
localement quelle est votre réaction ça
inquiète s'inquiète et puis mes mails ça
nous donne aussi le un petit peu une
vision de ce que pourrait être notre
avenir proche ce qui est évident c'est
que l'on ne pourra pas continuer de
façon générale il faut pas oublier que
on a confiné comme ça sans distinction
tous les territoires alors qu'il y avait
des territoires où le virus circule et
très peu on a confiné toutes les
générations alors que l'on sait que
c'est principalement les générations
plus âgées qui sont à risque parce que
nous ne disposions pas de masque parce
que nous disposions pas de test et parce
que nous ne l'avions pas l'expérience de
l' usage de ces moyens là maintenant
nous avons été en quelque sorte forme et
nous sommes plus aguerris et nous
disposons des matériels
à partir de là si l'on doit encore filer
parce que le virus circule davantage sur
certains territoires
cela devra se faire de façon partielle
mais il est probable que nous n'y
échapperons pas si le levier russes
veulent et a augmenté dans sa diffusion
merci jérôme marty d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france dont quelques
uns sont restés avec nous partirons en
l'émir qui ne s'est exprimé cet après
midi dans un discours à la nation et
aborder les résultats de la lutte contre
l'épidémie coronavirus et puis nous
parlerons de la main tendue par donald
trump à nicholas mais d'euros que
peut-elle bien caché une négociation
pour un départ pacifique du président
vénézuélien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur la rime paul
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il ya un état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
l'état a mis sur la table une série de
mesures pour aider le secteur 18
milliards d'euros pour le tourisme car
pour l'instant il ya les aides encore
les aides et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée bockel ça parle
beaucoup mais il faut il faut du concret
et les fonds de solidarité de 1500 euros
et ses terrasses et des pacotilles tout
ça c'est c'est mal fait c'est mal
préparée donc comment voulez vous que
les gens s'y retrouvent le plus dur
c'est à venir et c'est là où pour
l'heure le monde contrôlé ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus donc de toute
façon on est terminée dans une impasse
[Musique]
21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindrons direct sur rt france on part
maintenant en russie
la lumière poutine s'est exprimé cet
après midi dans un discours à la nation
il a abordé les résultats de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus à
moscou les précisions de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux le
président russe s'est globalement
félicité de la façon dont a été gérée la
crise dans son pays en commençant par la
fermeture rapide des frontières de la
russie en particulier avec la chine dès
les premiers moments de cette crise
sanitaire mais aussi à propos du système
de santé russes qui a globalement bien
encaissé le choc un chiffre pour
illustrer ce fait
l'alc la russie disposées au début de
cette crise de quarante mille lits pour
recueillir pour recevoir les malades du
corps n'avait russes ont donné
aujourd'hui à 120 milles et ce chiffre
va demeurer constant jusqu'à ce que
soient complètement oreiller cette crise
du coc vide 19 alors oui la menace recul
mais elle est toujours bien présente et
ne faut pas baisser la garde
comme l'a rappelé vladimir poutine tant
qu'un vaccin n'est pas mise au point est
distribué au plus grand nombre
encore aujourd'hui des milliers de
personnes chaque jour deviennent malades
donc je vous prie d'être vigilant
prudents jusqu'à ce que la production de
masse de médicaments
soit lancée aujourd'hui nos spécialistes
travaillent à l'élaboration à la
conception d'un vaccin les premiers
essais ont commencé je comprends bien
que tout le monde voudrait que un tel
médicament utile vienne le plus vite
possible mais les medics qui les
médecins s'en tiennent aux principes de
sûreté de sécurité et cela concerne
toutes les classes d'âge de la
population
vladimir poutine a également rappelé que
la conservation des emplois et des
salaires a toujours été sa priorité en
témoignent les mesures de période chômée
mais rémunéré adopté dès le début de la
période de confinement et pour relancer
l'activité économique
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées en
particulier la poursuite des allocations
familiales exceptionnel l'accès facilité
au crédit immobilier ou encore la hausse
de l'impôt sur le revenu mais uniquement
sur les ménages disposant d'un certain
niveau de ressources enfin il a eu un
mot concernant la grande consultation
populaire du 1er juillet concernant les
amendements à la constitution il a fait
savoir qu'il n'entrerait en vigueur ces
amendements constitutionnels que s'ils
étaient soutenus par la population
écoutez la réaction de gênes berg ancien
diplomate spécialiste de la russie
au lieu de faire une disposition comme
c'est quelqu'un en france où confinement
général qui ensuite département vert
orange et tout mais seuls à la fin mais
dès le départ il aller chez une certaine
attitude région vu l'immensité il ya
effeuiller n'était pas aussi vivent
partout en russie ch
on traite pas le cocasse comme on traite
la sibérie l'on traite pas mort comme on
traite sotchi et lassitude voire un
petit peu la philosophie
la russie a vu non seulement le tourisme
s'arrêter mais évidemment une perte fort
et j'ajoute c'est moins connu
les prix du gaz c'est encore décrocher
de plus en plus la russie a reçu ces
chocs qui est un outil qui est un peu
supérieur
à la récession qu'elle a connue en 2009
en 2009 c'est 7,9
là elle va connaître moins neuf mois
huit mois 9
la crainte d'une deuxième vague de
coronavirus au portugal la région de
lisbonne fait l'objet de nouvelles
mesures de confinement après
l'apparition de nouveaux foyers de
contagion et rassemblements de plus de
dix personnes sont de nouveau interdit
les cafés et restaurants ont fermé plus
tôt
le portugal qui a enregistré 9221
nouveaux cas depuis le 21 mai écouter
ses réactions
ce n'est pas de notre faute à nous les
cafés nous on suit les règles alors que
tous les groupes de personnes par
exemple qui vont à la plage ou qui vont
acheter des boissons alcoolisées aux
supermarchés aux stations-service là
dans ce cas il n'y a pas de problème ce
n'est pas de la faute des cafés et des
restaurants c'est vraiment pas bon c'est
une erreur on vit un grand problème et
nous devons tous avoir conscience de ce
qui se passe
moi par exemple avec mon âge je me suis
confiné le 14 mars
et je ne suis sorti que le 14 mai moi
j'ai ma conscience tranquille maintenant
avec ces décisions de tout ouvrir la
population a abusé de la situation
je comprenais seraient ceux qui
respectent les règles sont en train de
souffrir des mauvais comportement de
certains mauvais éléments de notre
société
comment ce virus atteinte tout le monde
comme ce virus atteint tout le monde il
faut prendre ces mesures même si cela
nous cause de gros préjudices
la situation n'était déjà pas bonne est
maintenant en nous enlevant encore une
heure d'ouverture
cela va avoir beaucoup de conséquences
pour nous dans cette période
mais outre atlantique est présent après
une relation chaotique donald trump et
nicolás maduro semblent prêts à
reprendre le dialogue peut être un début
pour une transition démocratique au
venezuela des explications de grazailles
à le président vénézuélien nicolas
maduro se dit prêt à discuter avec son
homologue américain si nécessaire je
suis prêt à discuter respectueusement
avec le président donald trump dans un
entretien publié dimanche donald trump a
ouvert la porte à une rencontre entre
les deux chefs d'état avant de poser
comme condition une sortie effective du
pouvoir contrairement à la gauche
radicale je serai toujours contre le
socialisme est avec le peuple du
venezuela
mon administration a toujours été du
côté de l'indépendance et de la liberté
et contre le régime oppressif de maduro
je ne rencontrerai maduro que pour
discuter d'une seule chose une sortie
pacifique du pouvoir
une invitation qui fait suite à une
attaque de son rival démocrate à la
présidence joe biden sur sa prétendue
admiration pour maduro trump parle
durement du venezuela mais il admire les
voyous et les dictateurs comme maduro la
réélection en 2018 de nicolás maduro a
toujours été rejetée par washington et
une cinquantaine d'autres pays préférant
reconnaître juan garrido comme président
légitime des sanctions financières sont
alors imposés par les états unis
sanctions jugées abusives par caracas
chaque fois que nous avons tenté de
procéder à un virement électronique
les transactions ont été rejetés ou
renvoyer sur le compte bancaire dans le
meilleur de coeur des sanctions qui
empêcherait notamment le venezuela
d'honorer sa dette auprès de
l'organisation internationale
près de 22 millions de dollars sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour rétablir
son droit de vote
quant à guido les etats-unis ont demandé
de mettre entre parenthèses ses
velléités présidentielles dans l'attenté
d'une prochaine échéance électorale et
ont proposé au venezuela un nouveau
cadre pour une transition démocratique
une proposition rejetée par caracas et
pour en parler nous sommes avec olivier
py ton avocat français au barreau de
washington observateurs de la vie
politique américaine
bonsoir olivier python merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france adore
donald trump a qui se dit prêt tout d'un
coup a rencontré nicolás maduro
concrètement ça veut dire quoi c'est un
renversement de stratégie on peut
l'interpréter comme ça en fait ce qui
est intéressant je trouve d'abord c'est
que c'est nicolas maduro qui avait fait
la première offre et que donald trump a
répondu qu'il était toujours prêt à
rencontrer tout le monde y compris
nicholas manou l'eau mais simplement
pour lui signifier pour lui montrer la
sortie parce qu'ils ne comptent négocier
que son que son rôle que son départ
pacifique
à noter quand même que dans ses
communiqués il ne cite pas gouedo pour
lequel il n'a pas une grande estime
ce qui fait que au bout du compte la
situation entre les états unis et le
venezuela paraît finalement assez bloqué
et on ne voit pas véritablement vers
quel type déchéance on pourrait aller je
pense que en l'occurrence on n'est plus
dans de l'affichage des deux côtés
d'ailleurs que dans une réelle volonté
d'aboutir à un accord entre les deux est
ce que c'est un petit peu prématuré
audacieux de dire que donald trump est
en train de lâcher juan jose haedo
non ce n'est pas totalement prématuré
c'est fort possible
en tout cas il ne donne pas de signes de
soutien particulièrement évident est
empressé donc incontestablement la
situation doit encore mûrir comme on dit
en langage diplomatique je suppose parce
que on ne peut pas demander le départ
d'un du président en exercice
sans pour autant être en mesure
d'accepter le la venue au pouvoir de son
opposant l'état ne peut pas rester
vacants alors au regard des autres cas
il semble de plus en plus en difficulté
contesté dans son propre camp dont un
train de vous l'avez bien expliqué qu'il
ne soutient plus comme avant est il
clairement en perte de vitesse et
bientôt en voie de disparition
c'est toujours le problème de la nature
qui a horreur du vide c'est à dire que
si une personnalité était susceptible de
remplacer
garrido dans l'esprit des américains oui
dans ce cas là il y aurait un plan b
pour l'instant je pense malgré tout que
le plan b reste garrido pour les
américains faute de mieux et même si il
ne semble pas le trouver particules en
tout cas donald trump ne semble pas le
trouver partir vraiment à son goût alors
comment vous voyez clairement
aujourd'hui une issue de la crise au
venezuela parce que ça fait quand même
plusieurs mois que ça dure ça fait même
plusieurs années que ça dure on a on a
une situation qui est complètement
bloquée avec un pouvoir qui est issu
donc du chavisme et qui est dans une
phase révolutionnaire assumer y compris
surtout en opposition aux états unis et
l'autre côté les américains qui
cherchent à contrôler le venezuela comme
ils cherchent à contrôler tous les états
je pense à pratiquer la bolivie tous les
états sud-américains qui ont eu des
velléités je dirais de 2,2
d'indépendance du moins d'autonomie via
le courant socialiste donc de toute
façon tant que maduro est au pouvoir au
venezuela
et même si trump devaient être battus au
mois de novembre la situation ne devrait
pas s'améliorer entre les deux pays
puisque je dirais que de manière
congénitales les deux les deux les deux
les deux idéologies ne peuvent pas
s'entendre mais justement c'était ma
prochaine question selon vous cette
présidentielle
dans quelques temps dans quelques mois
en quatre mois ne peut rien changer
effectivement cette situation c'est joe
biden par exemple emporté on se souvient
des mots très durs que maduro avait eu
pour barack obama c'est à dire qu'il
l'avait humilié il l'avait il avait
vraiment vraiment très très mal très
très mal traités hall notamment à
l'occasion des sommets des sommets année
d'aider des pays d amérique et on voit
mal joe biden qui se veut le successeur
l'héritier de barack obama s'il était
élu au mois de novembre
changer grand chose dans la vision que
les états unis peuvent avoir de nicolás
maduro et du et du venezuela de nicolás
maduro
c'est à dire que
le plus mal au changement d'exécutif aux
états unis il y a très très peu de
chances que temps que nicholas maduro
sera au pouvoir au venezuela que l'un
des deux pays est envie de faire
véritablement un effort ils sont de
manière je dirais presque parler de
manière totalement idéologique aux
antipodes l'un de l'autre ils sont en
opposition
l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre
particulièrement le venezuela qui fonde
une grande partie de son de sa
popularité sur l'anti-américanisme merci
olivier py temps d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre analyse ont démis
oblige le 22ème sommet union européenne
chine s'est tenue hier par
visioconférence bruxelles et pékin se
sont expliqués sur leurs relations
difficiles à propos notamment de
l'ouverture du marché chinois aux
investissements étrangers et la gestion
de la crise du coronavirus ou encore le
renforcement de la mainmise de pékin sur
hong kong les précisions avec françois
this qui évite les entretiens avec le
premier ministre puis avec le président
chi ont duré six heures mais aucune
déclaration commune n'a été fait et les
désaccords restent nombreux concernant
kong
si la chine rappelle que son action est
destinée à assurer sa sécurité et
s'oppose à toute ingérence étrangère
l'europe elle laisse planer la menace de
conséquences très négatives en cas
d'application de la loi de sécurité
imposées par pékin
la loi sur la sécurité nationale risque
de compromettre sérieusement le principe
un pays deux systèmes et le haut degré
d'autonomie deux choses que nous
souhaitons voir se maintenir
nous avons donc également fait savoir
que la chine risque d'avoir des
conséquences très négatives si elle
continue à imposer cette loi
l'union européenne est en contact avec
nos partenaires du g7 à ce sujet et nous
avons fait connaître très clairement
notre position aux dirigeants chinois
aujourd'hui et les avons exhorté à
reconsidérer leur position
la loi sur la sécurité nationale à hong
kong est une affaire interne à la chine
nous sommes opposés à toute ingérence
étrangère dans cette affaire un contexte
de méfiance accrue par la crise du
coronavirus
l'europe ainsi pu mesurer sa dépendance
à l'égard de la chine et accusent pékin
de désinformation pointant des cyber
attaques précise bruxelles est clair
cela ne peut pas être toléré
autre point de discussion et de
crispation les négociations entamées
depuis un an sur un accord sur la
protection des investissements qui
accorde aux entreprises européennes un
accès au marché chinois mais surtout les
protègent de l'appétit des grands
groupes chinois subventionnés sur
celui-là van der leyen espère que les
conditions seront réunies pour conclure
cet accord avant la fin de l'année les
européens sont pour l'instant déçu oui
comme chez news nous continuons
d'observer des déséquilibres dans nos
relations commerciales nous n'avons pas
pu progresser sur les différents points
qui avait été noté lors du dernier
sommet et en particulier par rapport à
l'accès au marché alors il faudra
avancer sur ces fonds c'est urgent et il
faut également un regain d'ambition
chinoise sur l'accord relatif aux
investissements
un regain d'ambition demande également
par bruxelles à pékin dans la mise en
oeuvre de ses engagements pour le climat
alors que la chine représentant un quart
des émissions mondiales de gaz à effet
de serre a récemment construit de
nouvelles centrales au charbon etc a
rien là maintenu à s'exprimer sur la loi
controversée sur la sécurité nationale à
hong kong pour la dirigeante de
l'exécutif chinois elle vise à rétablir
la stabilité dans l'ancienne colonie
sans violer le cadre un pays deux
systèmes écouter l'autorité de beaucoup
de chose réside dans la loi fondamentale
et c'est la loi fondamentale qui a donné
à hong kong sa prospérité et sa
stabilité au cours des 23 dernières
années
il continuera à le faire
que nous ne nous écarterons pas de la
loi fondamentale depuis le 18 juin les
ivoiriens sont invités à se faire
enrôler sur les listes électorales en
vue de l'élection présidentielle
d'octobre 2020 la commission électorale
indépendante chargée de cette opération
a déployé 35 mille agents sur le
territoire quinze jours d'opération pour
inscrire tous les nouveaux majeurs du
pays l'objectif à quelques mois du
scrutin et dans le relais près de 5
millions de nouveaux votants pour porter
à 11 millions le nombre d'électeurs sur
une population de 25 millions reportage
à la haye où et ghislain mèneront pas
dans ce quartier populaire d'abidjan un
collège transformé en centre
d'inscription électorale de futurs
électeurs
parmi eux certains voteront pour la
première fois en octobre
j'aimerais un peu plus côté parce que
ça va me libérer à l'intérieur de moi
même
et à lester parce que quand tu es quand
tu es un citoyen de tout prix et que tu
participes tue pas si bas à tous et qui
sait pas dans ton pays tu te sens libéré
la raison pour laquelle c'est matt et
messieurs les vvd faglaro les mois comme
c'est le cas dans les onze mille centres
d'enrôlement que compte la côte d'ivoire
cet établissement n'atteint pas ses
objectifs
seulement 260 inscrits en huit jours
dont 80% de nouveaux majeurs maintenant
on prend le cas des nomades
quand il arrive à point le formulaire
les informations sur le formulaire
elle recèle sa sur la tablette après ça
evard plat peser vu la photo après la
photo est passé aux emplois les besoins
cela dit les dix doigts plus les deux
centex voilà après ça est passé
maintenant
après les emplois c'est la signature du
récurrent pour la signature du récurrent
elle vérifie bien que les informations
sont exactes
avant l'enregistrement autre problème
plus de la moitié des candidats à
l'inscription ne dispose pas des
documents nécessaires certains déplorent
un manque d'implication des jeunes
provenant de mots mais dame et qu'elle
même âge que moi raisons peu
d'engouement parce que nos prières sans
qu'ils sont pas tous motivés alors le
moment venu voter
vous n'êtes pas mais il ya tant que les
nouveaux majeurs ne soient pas nombreux
labels fait l'enrôlement la commission
électorale indépendante vise cinq
millions de nouvelles inscriptions sur
les listes électorales
objectif 11 millions de votants sur 25
millions d'habitants au total
j'essaie d'expliquer à tout le monde que
la politique l affaire de tous et
s'inscrire sur une liste électorale
c'est de jouer son rôle citoyenne
pourquoi tu y vois le voit que n'étant
pas obligatoire ça n'intéresse pas
certaines personnes et surtout les
jeunes ce qu'elle disait souvent c'est
la sphère des vieux dans un pays où 70
7% de la population a moins de 35 ans la
mobilisation des nouveaux votants un
enjeu dont se saisit le monde politique
le f pays le parti de l'ex président
laurent gbagbo par exemple après dix
années de boycott des élections
ce parti d'opposition voilà son possible
retour dans le jeu électoral avec
quelques 400 mille nouveaux inscrits
soit seulement 6 % de l'objectif
escompté
la commission envisage de prolonger les
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
qui doivent s'achever le 24 juin
là c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes à 22 heures pile
rester avec mon frère tu es fou
[Musique]
elle
je
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez de résilience
comment est ce qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement humain font 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant mais on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision invraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend telles valeurs on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins il
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
une très belle vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
où
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
principe même de notre association c'est
de réduire les inégalités d'accès à la
santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rencontre que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terre j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais si j'ai bien compris ils
sont morts pour rien puisque au nom
d'une idéologie on nie leur existence en
oubliant une partie de la game
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 back soon
arrow ni la gravité la date en 2000 il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie et pour le développement
global car nous avons besoin aussi
d'être en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
à cette reprise cédric souvient indiqué
aux policiers qui l'étouffé résultats
d'une expertise rendue publique
aujourd'hui
ce livre est mort à la suite d'un
contrôle policier début janvier à paris
des policiers désormais sous la menace
d'une mise en examen la famille de la
victime réclame leur suspension et des
actions du gouvernement contre les
violences policières
l'allemagne qui décrète un deuxième
reconfirme en local le premier concerne
notamment un canton de 360 milles
habitants dans l'ouest du pays mis à
l'isolément jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juin une mesure décrétée après
l'apparition d'un foyer de contamination
dans un grand abattoir où plus de 1500
cas d'infection ont été détectés cette
mesure vise à calmer la situation et
accroître les tests
en russie vladimir poutine s'est adressé
à la nation cet après midi plus d'un
mois après le défilement qui a débuté le
12 mai dernier le président a dressé le
bilan préliminaire de la lutte contre le
corona virus est abordé la situation
économique
le défilé de la victoire aura par
ailleurs bien lieu ce mercredi au but
du 9 mai en raison de la pandémie de
kobe de 19
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france du nouveau dans la
sphère cédric joue via on a appris la
garde à vue de quatre fonctionnaires de
police pendant son interpellation ce
père de famille a crié j'étouffe à sept
reprises
les faits remontent au 3 janvier 2020 au
bord de seine à paris ce livreur de 42
ans est victime d'une fracture du larynx
après une interpellation il décède deux
jours plus tard à l'hôpital des vidéos
tournées par la victime ont conduit la
justice à placer les quatre policiers
mis en cause en garde à vue une
information judiciaire est ouverte pour
homicide involontaire ses avocats
dénoncent les méthodes d'arrestation de
la police et précision avec notre
reporter quatre sacres et outre la
sphère ctq souvient rebondi
selon des enregistrements récemment
versé au dossier d' enquêtes judiciaires
le père de famille a crié cette fois
j'étouffe avant de perdre connaissance
le 3 janvier 2020 il décédera deux jours
plus tard des suites d'une fracture du
larynx occasionnés par son
immobilisation par une clé
d'étranglement et par un placage
ventrale depuis le début la famille de
cédric joue via crient à la bavure
policière se trouve que ces
enregistrements que se sont procurés le
monde et mediapart vont peser dans l'
enquête judiciaire
ils contredisent les propos des quatre
policiers qui avaient procédé à sept
interpellations
les avocats de la famille souvient
aujourd'hui ont tenu une conférence de
presse je vous propose de les écouter ce
qui a conduit à la mort de cédric joue
via c'est un enchaînement inexorable
c'est-à-dire ce chantage à loutre âge
qui est provoquée à chaque fois que des
personnes sont contrôlées les
fonctionnaires de police quand il
contrôle des gens savent qu'ils ont une
dissymétrie et qu'ils peuvent les
poursuivre pour outrage et donc il ya
une provocation à l'outragé face à un
homme et de rien a rappelé tragiquement
qui dit je ne peux plus respirer cette
fois dondon dans les jambes et frappe le
bac adam pour dire qu'il est pas loin
l'agonie les policiers de façon tout à
fait insensé fonds linverse
c'est à dire s'arrêter des experts de
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale ont donc analysé
13 vidéos dont celle de cédric joue via
et de la policière présente sur les
lieux
il dispose également d'un enregistrement
sonore de 12 minutes
il a été effectué grâce à un micro qui
se trouvait dans le casque de cédric
joue via les experts ont rendu un
rapport le 21 avril il déclare je cite
l'échangé relativement correcte même si
nous pouvons ressentir une forme de
défiance et de provocation dans les
paroles de la personne contrôlée selon
l' enquête de l'igpn est les quatre
policiers auraient déclaré que cédric
souvient s'est montré irrespectueux
agressif et menaçant
et ce sont ces outrages qui aurait mené
à l'interpellation
or à l'écouté des enregistrements où se
rend compte que cédric souvient a bien
adopté un ton provocateur mais les
insultes en question son guignol clowns
ou encore pauvre type
nulle trace d'agressivité ni de menaces
dans ses propos en revanche à des
policiers a eu un commentaires
dégradants
il a dit aux livreurs tu veux pas que je
me mettre à quatre pattes et que je te
je vous laisse imaginer la vulgarité des
propos tenus les quatre policiers
impliqués dans l'interpellation de
cédric jovial ont été entendus le 17
juin à la demande du juge d'instruction
entendu en garde à vue c'est une
procédure rare mais ils n'ont pas été
suspendu et leur mise en examen ne reste
qu'une éventualité
les avocats de la famille ont en tout
cas à déposer une plainte avec
constitution de partie civile pour
violence volontaire d'une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
les avocats de la famille demande en
outre à christophe castaner d'interdire
le placage ventrale est la clé
d'étranglement des techniques décriés
pour leur dangerosité potentielle et
pour christian souvient le père de
cédric jovial injustices de cette
affaire règne toujours
c'était dur rendre ça on l'a supporté
parce que on pensait bien que cédric
était pas mort en muet par contre qu'il
avait affaire à des sourds puisque
ils n'ont pas entendu qu'ils disent est
cette fois je respire plus je respire
plus je respire plus je respire plus je
respire plus je respire plus je respire
plus je suis super ne pas m'être trompé
ils n'ont pas entendu parce que
maintenant on a appris que dans la
police on embauche a aussi des sourds
dont il ya pile handicap aujourd'hui
bientôt on
il faudrait peut-être commencer
embaucher des manchots pour éviter la
clé d'étranglement
cédric est mort le 3 janvier il est mort
le 3 janvier aux alentours de 10h 10h30
sur le pavé de paris
il est pas mort à l'hôpital il était
déjà mort cliniquement quand ils
arrivent à l'hôpital il avait plus de
cerveau on a revu en nahar fait démarrer
son coeur parce que c'était c'était
c'était mieux qui meurent à l'hôpital
que sur le pavé savez ça faisait mauvais
genre pour la police ma famille mes
enfants mes petits enfants
ma fille ma femme ronde on n'est pas
d'accord son épouse ait pas d'accord
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
faut arrêter la clé d'étranglement faut
arrêter le placage ventrale moi je vais
leur donner une solution puisque tous
ces cerveaux qu'on fait qu'on fait l'ena
qu'on fait tout ça il n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu' il suffit de le contrôler
et de prendre son nom son adresse
parce qu'il a donné ces documents il a
donné ses papiers il est en règle
ils ont mis une amende je crois ou deux
je sais pas s'ils ont mis des pv mais
j'ai pas encore le rapport mais il a
donné ses papiers puisqu'ils y ont donné
donc il a bien pris la parfumerie
d'obtempérer il a donné ses papiers
donc il est en règle je donne mais
demain vous me les coupe et demain il
n'a jamais sorti une grossièreté une
violence de sa part il a juste dit je
vous file parce que je vais porter
plainte
vous m'avez bousculer on m'avait poussé
vous m'avez insulté je vais porter
plainte alors c'est pas tout la police
ya comme ça faut pas non plus à
extrapoler on n'en veut pas la police on
n'est pas des anti policiers et dans
tout etat il faut il faut une police des
fois une police qui soit juste pas une
police qui quand vous avez travaillé le
matin vous tuer on les défend on cache
tout on dissimule tout pour pas que vous
ayez raison c'est pas un accident c'est
un mot que aujourd'hui on peut pas
employer dans la sphère de mon fils on
peut pas dire c'est un l'accident il
était coursier s'il avait eu un accident
il ya un camion qui lui sera il y aurait
roulé dessus
c'était différent c'était un accident un
accident bas professionnelle parce que
c'est un métier dangereux
là c'est pas un accident professionnel
c'est un contrôle car qui aujourd'hui a
mal tourné parce que
il ya une deux trois ou quatre personnes
qu'on dit à un moment donné on s'arrête
pas on va pas s'arrêter et à six jours
du deuxième tour des municipales on en
vient ces révélations de mediapart selon
le journal un député laetitia vient à
candidate aux élections dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris aurait utilisé
ses ressources parlementaire pour mener
sa campagne électorale une pratique
proscrites à la fois par le règlement de
l'assemblée le livre de la commission
nationale des comptes de campagne et le
code électoral les accusations qu aurait
nié en bloc la candidate la reine par le
biais de son avocat toujours selon
mediapart et sur l'emploi des assistants
parlementaires écoutez le la vie de nos
invités civile d'helmand chercheurs
associés pour l'institut thomas more et
et didier maïsto président de sud radio
comment vous les qualifier un emploi
fictif appartement n'existe pas de
définition de cet enfant c'est à ses
adhérents et là en fait souvent il ya
des conclusions de genre qui s'opère au
niveau de l'utilisation des ressources
en matière de ressources humaines
constituent des assistants
parlementaires à faire la diff en
parlementaire il peut à s'occuper du
courrier il peut s'occuper d'organiser
des manifestations d'organiser des
réunions il peut s'occuper de l'agenda
mais il va aussi à rédiger à des
questions écrites des propositions de
loi ou à des amendements donc en fait
tout dépend de tout dépend de la
définition que le parlementaire va
donner à la fonction de son assistant
parlementaire
c'est un flou savamment et sciemment
entretenu parce qu'en fait ce sont des
contrats de droit privé avec de l'argent
public avec un contrat de confiance qui
est uniquement qui est unilatéral en
fait un le député moi j'ai fait ce
boulot aussi peu le rompre à tout moment
et donc vous êtes un petit peu je vais
pas employer les grands mots mais
l'esclave du du député vous dépendre de
son bon vouloir et allez soyons
magnanimes 90% des parts le dd députés
utilisent leur réussite leur assistant
parlementaire pour ce pour laurent blanc
bon vouloir coller des affiches vers les
campagnes électorales municipales
10 amendement rédigé des discours de
telle sorte que souvent les députés
paraissent le mardi et le mercredi lors
des questions d'actualité mais dans la
soute
il y a les assistants parlementaires le
coronavirus à présent l'immunité
collective est insuffisante pour
empêcher une deuxième vague en france le
conseil scientifique alerte ainsi sur un
retour extrêmement probable de
l'épidémie à l'automne la france n'a
donc pas fini avec le comique 19
alors pour mieux surveiller son
évolution les experts qui accompagne le
gouvernement depuis le début de la crise
préconise de conserver les données de
santé recueillies tout au long de
l'épidémie à des fins de recherche et de
suivi épidémiologique
alors comment éviter cette seconde vague
que tout le monde craint pour benjamin
david o infectiologues à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches le meilleur
moyen est de tester massivement et
d'isoler les balades
ces foyers il faut finalement sont
félicités parce qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle il ya plus de 151 de mémoire
cluster identifiés en france
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
était capable d'empêcher le virus de se
propager la plus grande ampleur
notamment au niveau des départements et
des régions est de faire en sorte
d'avoir les conditions d'une deuxième
vague au sens de la première c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on parle de deuxième
bague il faut comprendre qu'on parle des
malades à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui les malades à l'hôpital sont
extrêmement rares ya très peu de
nouvelles entrées à l'hôpital parce que
justement on arrive à empêcher ces
malades de faire défendre sévère puisque
on diagnostique chez des gens souvent
jeunes et son appel peau si certains ont
peu ou pas de symptômes et qu'on isole
immédiatement et l'objectif comme l'a
rappelé le président de ms c'est de
détecter massivement pour pouvoir
bloquer les chaînes de transmission en
isolant les cas qui sont contaminés sur
le bilan du coronavirus dans l'hexagone
le nombre de cas graves en réanimation
poursuit sa baisse avec 683 malades soit
19 de moins par rapport à hier
selon la direction générale de la santé
la france a enregistré 57 morts liés aux
commis 19
dans les hôpitaux ces dernières 24
heures au total 29 mille sept cent vingt
personnes sont décédées depuis le début
de l'épidémie et pour jérôme marty
médecin généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre si
l'on souhaite protéger la population sur
la durée les masses pourrait être encore
obligatoire c'est difficile de respecter
ces fameux gestes-barrières de changer
nos vies pendant des semaines et des
semaines et des semaines et donc dans
des moments comme ça festifs comme la
fête de la musique on peut voir un
certain relâchement maintenant ce que
l'on doit observer c'est que dans les
grands magasins dans les hôpitaux dans
les ehpad dans d'autres lieux
on doit reconnaître que les gestes
barrières sont respectés maintenant des
transports en commun aussi mais ce sont
des lieux au souvent le port du masque
est obligatoire peut-être faut-il garder
cette obligation pour un certain nombre
de lieux il faut surtout tester tester
tester testé massivement souvent
aléatoirement pour savoir comment ceci
avait juste circulent à quel taux afin
de savoir si oui ou non il y à une
augmentation de sa propagation
les crises du coup on a un virus en
allemagne déjà concerné par un
confinement local berlin en annonçant
deuxième cela fait suite à l'apparition
d'un important foyer de contamination
dans un abattoir le récit de florian
lambert alors que le déconfinement se
poursuit en europe l'allemagne est
contrainte à 2 quarantaine locales après
la région de lisbonne au portugal
c'est l'ensemble du canton voisin de
warendorf et celui de goûteurs slot qui
sont concernés par un recond finement
pour ce dernier
lundi soir les autorités locales ont
annoncé que mille cinq cent cinquante
trois personnes avaient été contaminées
par le cobp et 19 dans un grand abattoir
de la région quelque 7000 personnes ont
été placées en quarantaine
21 autres sont hospitalisées dont six en
soins intensifs et ce mec est le but est
de calmer la situation
et d'étendre les tests pour établir si
le virus s'est diffusé dans la
population via les salariés de
l'abattoir theunis sénat seront
confinement prévu dans un premier temps
jusqu'au 30 juin contre 1 de nouveau ce
canton à une limitation stricte des
contacts à la fermeture des bars des
cinémas et des musées ainsi qu'à
l'interdiction des activités de loisirs
dans les espaces fermés
ces mesures drastiques interviennent à
dix jours des vacances scolaires dans un
canton qui compte 360 mille habitants
mais les autorités allemandes se veulent
optimistes concernant la menace d'une
deuxième vague
je pense qu'une deuxième vague peut
toujours arriver et elle peut bien sûr
survenir en allemagne je suis cependant
très optimiste parce que les gens savent
que s'ils continuent de se comporter en
faisant attention
et puisque les événements de grande
ampleur ne sont toujours pas autorisés
nous pourrons éviter cette deuxième
vague
tahar sfar et evergreen dunkel
l'allemagne compte à ce jour plus de 190
mille cas pour 8969 décès branson
membres de la chambre des représentants
de berlin la situation démographique de
l'allemagne profite à la propagation du
virus est également de mettre toute une
région et on ne peut pas définir deux
régions pandémique voyages et le
tourisme
dans une région où il ya un nouveau
complément du à la cofidis conditions ne
sont pas dues à la guerre la plupart des
travailleurs vient de l'étranger et
vivent une grande promiscuité c'était un
milieu idéal pour la contamination
en angleterre le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson annonce ce
soir des règles du déconfinement dans
les secteurs du tourisme et de la
restauration aller coûte à partir du 4
juillet les locaux suivants pourront
rouvrir à condition qu'ils soient
sécurisés contre le coc vide
hôtels chambres d'hôtes et logements de
vacances indépendant parc de caravanes
et de camping lieux de culte et
bibliothèque restaurants et cafés bars
pubs discothèques cinémas et salles de
bingo musées et galeries salon de
coiffure et barbier terrain de jeu et
salles de sport en plein air à taux
plein
nathalie mais je dois vous dire que si
le virus commencé à échapper à tout
contrôle je n'hésiterai pas à freiner à
revenir en arrière sur certains de ces
changements bosse on part maintenant en
russie vladimir poutine s'est exprimé
cet après midi dans un discours à la
nation il a abordé les résultats de la
lutte contre l'épidémie de coronavirus à
moscou les précisions de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux le
président russe s'est globalement
félicité de la façon dont a été gérée la
crise dans son pays en commençant par la
fermeture rapide des frontières de la
russie en particulier avec la chine dès
les premiers
moment de cette crise sanitaire mais
aussi à propos du système de santé
russes qui a globalement bien encaissé
le choc un chiffre pour illustrer ce
fait
l'alc la russie disposées au début de
cette crise de quarante mille lits pour
recueillir pour recevoir les malades du
camp n'avait russes ont donné
aujourd'hui à 120 milles et ce chiffre
va demeurer constant jusqu'à ce que
soient complètement enrayé cette crise
du coc vide 19 alors oui la menace recul
mais elle est toujours bien présente et
ne faut pas baisser la garde
comme l'a rappelé vladimir poutine tant
qu'un vaccin n'est pas mise au point est
distribué au plus grand nombre
encore aujourd'hui des milliers de
personnes chaque jour deviennent malades
donc je vous prie d'être vigilant
prudents jusqu'à ce que la production de
masse de médicaments
soit lancée aujourd'hui nos spécialistes
travaillent à l'élaboration et la
conception d'un vaccin les premiers
essais ont commencé je comprends bien
que tout le monde voudrait qu'un tel
médicament utile vienne le plus vite
possible mais les medics qui les
médecins s'en tiennent aux principes de
sûreté de sécurité et cela concerne
toutes les classes d'âge de la
population
vladimir poutine a également rappelé que
la conservation des emplois et des
salaires a toujours été sa priorité en
témoignent les mesures de période chômée
mais rémunéré adopté dès le début de la
période de confinement et pour relancer
l'activité économique
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées en
particulier la poursuite des allocations
familiales exceptionnel l'accès facilité
au crédit immobilier ou encore la hausse
de l'impôt sur le revenu mais uniquement
sur les ménages disposant d'un certain
niveau de ressources enfin il a eu un
mot concernant la grande consultation
populaire du 1er juillet concernant les
amendements à la constitution il a fait
savoir qu'il n'entrerait en vigueur ces
amendements constitutionnels que s'ils
étaient soutenus par la population
et selon eugène berg ancien diplomate
spécialiste de la russie la stratégie de
venir poutine et d'avoir laissé les
acteurs locaux décider des modalités de
confinement une tactique payante sedan
sont à l'aise au lieu de faire une
disposition comme c'est quelqu'un en
france où confinement général qui
ensuite département vert orangé tout
message à la fin mais dès le départ il
aller chez une certaine intitulé région
vu l'immensité il ya les foyers
n'étaient pas aussi vif partout en
russie
on traite pas le cocasse contre est
libéré on traite pas mort comme on
traite sotchi et la cité un petit peu la
philosophie
la russie a vu non seulement le tourisme
s'arrêter mais évidemment une perte fort
et j'ajoute c'est moins connu
les prix du gaz c'est encore décrocher
de plus en plus la russie
a reçu ce choc qui aiment ce qui est un
peu supérieur à la récession qu'elle a
connue en 2009 en 2009 7,9
là elle va connaître - 9 - 8 - 9 mai
outre-atlantique à présent prêt une
relation chaotique donald rebelles
nicolás maduro semblent prêts à
reprendre le dialogue peut être un début
pour une transition démocratique au
venezuela les explications de graff
d'aia mais président vénézuélien nicolas
maduro se dit prêt à discuter avec son
homologue américain si nécessaire je
suis prêt à discuter respectueusement
avec le président donald trump dans un
entretien publié dimanche donald trump a
ouvert la porte à une rencontre entre
les deux chefs d'état avant de poser
comme condition une sortie effective du
pouvoir contrairement à la gauche
radicale je serai toujours contre le
socialisme est avec le peuple du
venezuela
mon administration a toujours été du
côté de l'indépendance et de la liberté
et contre le régime oppressif de maduro
je ne rencontrerai maduro que pour
discuter d'une seule chose une sortie
pacifique du pouvoir
une invitation qui fait suite à une
attaque de son rival démocrate à la
présidence joe biden sur sa prétendue
admiration pour maduro trump parle du
roman du venezuela mais il admire les
voyous et les dictateurs comme maduro la
réélection dé me 10,8 de nicolás maduro
a toujours été rejetée par washington et
une cinquantaine d'autres pays préférant
reconnaître juan garrido comme président
légitime des sanctions financières sont
alors imposés par les états unis
sanctions jugées abusives par caracas
chaque fois que nous avons tenté de
procéder à un virement électronique
les transactions ont été rejetés ou
renvoyer sur nos comptes bancaires dans
le meilleur de coeur des sanctions qui
empêcherait notamment le venezuela
d'honorer sa dette auprès de
l'organisation internationale
près de 22 millions de dollars sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour rétablir
son droit de vote
quant à guido les etats-unis lui ont
demandé de mettre entre parenthèses ses
velléités présidentielles dans l'attenté
d'une prochaine échéance électorale et
ont proposé au venezuela un nouveau
cadre pour une transition démocratique
une proposition rejetée par caracas
la dépit de 18 juin les ivoiriens sont
invités à s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales en vue de l'élection
présidentielle d'octobre 2020 la
commission électorale indépendante
chargée de cette opération a déployé 35
mille agents sur le territoire quinze
jours d'opération pour enrôler tous les
nouveaux majeurs du pays
l'objectif à quelques mois du scrutin et
d'obtenir près de 5 millions de nouveaux
votants pour porter à 11 millions le
nombre d'électeurs sur une population de
25 millions reportage d'alain à limoux
et ghislaine romsa dans ce quartier
populaire d'abidjan un collège
transformé en centre d'inscription
électorale de futurs électeurs
parmi eux certains voteront pour la
première fois en octobre
j'aimerais a pu voter parce que
ça va me libérer à l'intérieur de moi
même et à l'estivé parce que quand tu es
quand tu es un citoyen de tous pays et
que tu participes
tu participes à tous et qui sait pas
dans ton pays tu te sens libéré la
raison pour laquelle c'est matt et
messieurs les vérifs à la rolls et moi
comme c'est le cas dans les onze mille
centres d'enrôlement que compte la côte
d'ivoire cet établissement n'atteint pas
ses objectifs
seulement 260 inscrits en huit jours
dont 80% de nouveaux majeurs maintenant
on prend le cas des nomades
quand il arrive à pour le formuler les
informations sur le formulaire
aircelle ça sur la tablette après ça
elle va plaire à peu j'ai vu la photo
après la photo est parce qu aux emplois
les blues ont précédé les dix doigts
plus de 200 experts après ça est passé
maintenant
après les en pointe c'est la signature
du récurrent
voilà sinon c'est récurrent elle vérifie
bien que les informations sont exactes
avant l'enregistrement autre problème
plus de la moitié des candidats à
l'inscription ne dispose pas des
documents nécessaires certains déplorent
un manque d'implication des jeunes
autonomes hommes et dames et qu'elle
même âge que moi réhaussant peu
d'engouement pascal le sourire sans
qu'ils sont patents motivés alors le
manque de nouveautés
je ne sais pas mais notons que les
nouveaux majeurs ne sont pas nombreux à
l enrôlement la commission électorale
indépendante vise cinq millions de
nouvelles inscriptions sur les listes
électorales
objectif 11 millions de votants sur 25
millions d'habitants au total
j'essaie d'expliquer à tout le monde que
la politique est l affaire de tous et
s'inscrire sur une liste électorale
c'est de jouer son rôle citoyenne
pourquoi cette voie le vote n'étant pas
obligatoire ça n'intéresse pas certaines
personnes et surtout les jeunes ce
qu'elle disait souvent seul à faire des
vieux dans un pays où 70 7% de la
population a moins de 35 ans la
mobilisation des nouveaux votants un
enjeu dont se saisit le monde politique
le f pays le parti de l'ex président
laurent gbagbo par exemple après dix
années de boycott des élections
ce parti d'opposition voilà son possible
retour dans le jeu électoral avec
quelques 400 mille nouveaux inscrits
soit seulement 6 % de l'objectif
escompté
la commission envisage de prolonger les
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
qui doivent s'achever le 24 juin
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain prince par
l'actualité demain matin 7 heures du
matin heure française excellente fin de
soirée à tous
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
et